bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ces nouveaux cours de paléontologie
alors on va finir l'été en douceur en
légèreté avec des cours qui seront de
niveau première année de licence
d'habitude je donne des cours qui sont
plutôt de niveau master ou équivalent
mais là cette fois on va terminer avec
trois petits cours relativement simple
qui sont de niveau première année
puisque je donne aussi cours au niveau
première année et donc le court qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui va être intitulé la
paléontologie
qu'est ce que c'est en quoi ça consiste
la paléontologie
donc c'est un cours que je donne
normalement aux premières années de
géologie il faut savoir qu'en afrique du
sud là où je donne cours la
paléontologie et la géologie sont deux
choses relativement séparés c'est pas
vraiment ça il n'y a pas vraiment de
pont entre les deux entre les deux
disciplines
du moins sur le papier il y en a mais en
pratique les géologues connaissent assez
peu de choses en fait de la
paléontologie est les paléontologues
connaissent assez peu de choses de la
géologie tout simplement ben parce que
l'afrique du sud l'afrique du sud c'est
un pays minier donc les géologues sont
surtout entraîné à a participé à
l'industrie minière est pas tellement à
faire de la recherche
or la paléontologie c'est un milieu en
en afrique du sud
une fois encore la paléontologie c'est
un milieu qui fait exclusivement de la
recherche
donc les les ressources paléontologique
sont pas tellement utilisé dans
l'industrie minière est évidemment
l'industrie minière a quasiment aucune
incidence sur la paléontologie à part
quand il faut faire des fouilles
préventives puisque les fouilles
préventives paléontologiques en afrique
du sud ça existe ça n'existe pas en
france en france on fait des fouilles
préventives pour l'archéologie mais pas
pour la paléontologie
mais c'est à peu près le seul la seule
opportunité en afrique du sud que les
deux champs d'investigation les deux
champs de recherche se chevauchent c'est
pendant les faits pendant les fouilles
préventives
donc en gros les géologues connaissent
rien à la paléontologie les
paléontologues n'ont pas besoin de
connaître grand chose à l'ag
logis en afrique du sud alors c'est pas
vrai tout le temps évidemment c'est
beaucoup plus vrai maintenant que ça ne
l'était par le passé par le passé les
paléontologues était de toute façon
issus des écoles de géologie donc avant
avant de la précédente génération de
chercheur en paléontologie était un peu
mieux entraînées à la paléontologie mais
c'est vrai que maintenant la plupart de
nos paléontologues viennent du milieu
zoologique et plus tellement du milieu
géologique donc ces essais un shift qui
est globale c'est à dire que ça se passe
aussi en france à ce chiffre les les
paléontologues d'aujourd'hui sont
beaucoup plus des biologistes reconverti
à la paléontologique dès que des
géologues reconverti à la paléontologie
donc ils connaissent mieux les objets
d'étude mais ils connaissent beaucoup
moins bien le contexte
bon bah c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
savoir qu'on pense et évidemment faut
savoir travailler par soi même c'est ça
l'université il faut faire ses propres
recherches dans l'est dans les
bibliothèques universitaires
mais bref voilà c'est juste pour la
petite introduction sait que ça va être
secours c'est un cours de niveau
première année qui va être très très
introductif voilà donc il est possible
que vous sachiez déjà la plupart des
choses que je vais vous dire maintenant
mais il est possible aussi que vous ayez
envie de partager cette vidéo avec des
gens à qui vous voulez faire découvrir
la paléontologie
ça peut être ça peut être une bonne idée
voilà et encore une fois je vais garder
ce point de vue africain d'où cette
image magnifique petite image d'ailleurs
je les aime beaucoup parce que on voit
en fait ca ressort produit une colonne
stratigraphique sur le continent
africain donc on commence avec les diack
a ras le
les trilobites ici ici vous avez donc le
permien le permien du caroux et puis
quand on monte ici vous avez les
dinosaures qui sortent avec notamment
masos pon di luce sud-africain aussi les
le volcanisme du drakensberg qui est
intelligemment représenté en afrique de
l'est où on a du volcanisme cénozoïque
et puis vous avez enfin les mammifères
et les êtres humains les êtres humains
robond parce qu'ils sont en haut de la
colonne stratigraphique parce qu'ils
sont sommés de l'évolution mais bon
évidemment d'un point de vue strictement
stratigraphique les humains sont parmi
les derniers arrivés et les outils des
paléontologues avec avec normalement il
ya un rouleau de pq quelque part mais
peut-être que peut-être que je les ai
enlevés juste pour ce que les premières
années n'était pas n'étaient pas prêts à
voir le rouleau de pq en tant qu' en
tant qu'outil du paléontologue je crois
qu'il était là j'ai dû le retirer
mais normalement il ya un rouleau de pq
sur cette image parce que papa parce que
sur le terrain on en a besoin pour
protéger les fossiles entre autres donc
voilà alors c'est parti pour qu'est ce
que c'est la paléontologie
alors d'abord quelques définitions
évidemment on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
faire une série introductif sur les
définitions donc paléontologie ah oui
alors en anglais il est plein
paléontologie enfin en british
c'est avec un as et en amérique
incessants à si un jour vous vous posez
la question de savoir pourquoi il n'y a
pas là et ontologique et des fois il n'y
a pas des ontologies c'est parce que les
british en fait ils ont repris le ils
ont repris le la façon d'écrire à la
grecque alors que les alors que les
américains l'ont enlevé
donc ils les paient le plus à la
française d'ailleurs donc la
paléontologie c'est la discipline qui
s'intéresse aux fossiles
du coup la définition suivante c'est
mais qu'est ce donc qu'un fossile et oui
un fossile c'est une trace de vie ou une
trace d'activité laissé par la vie et
préserver dans la roche et ça c'est
important comme définition parce que ça
veut dire que n'importe quelle trace
laissée par une activité animal végétal
ou bactérienne est considéré comme un
fossile donc on va voir un petit
exercice juste après ça qui va nous qui
va nous montrer qu est ce que ça
recouvre finalement comme comme champ de
possibles cette définition
ces traces de vie enfin ouais c'est ces
traces de vie ces fossiles n'ont pas
appartenir à des espèces éteintes par
exemple il ya des traces fossiles d'homo
sapiens donc c'est pas forcément reliés
aux espèces éteintes une espèce éteinte
peut ne pas être un fossile comme par
exemple les mammouths congelés
c'est à dire qu un mammouth un os de
mammouth qui s'est transformé en ruche
est un fossile par contre 1 à mouthe
congelés techniquement n'est pas un
fossile donc ça c'est important
c'est très très important à retenir
parce que le mammouth congelé finalement
il est dans le même état que quand il
est mort juste qu'il est congelé
maintenant mais c'est pas parce que
c'est une espèce éteinte que c'est un
fossile par contre ça reste du champ de
la paléontologie puisqu'il appartient à
une espèce et anne qu'on retrouve par
ailleurs sous forme de faux cils donc
bon juste pour dire que comme toutes les
définitions elle tente d'établir des
barrières solide mais que ces barrières
sont extrêmement poreuse possible
et une petite justification encore une
fois je donne un point de vue africain
et particulièrement sud africain sur la
paléontologie
j'utilise du vocabulaire anglais dans ce
court d'une part parce que je parle pas
un broc de langage locaux et d'autre
part je parle à peine anglais d'ailleurs
mais donc j'utilise le vocabulaire
anglais surtout parce qu'il n'ya pas de
vocabulaire dans les langues locales
c'est-à-dire l'afrikaans en afrique du
sud
ils ont quelques mots pour parler des
fossiles mais ces mots sont directement
dérivé de l'anglais
et puis les langues locales local pour
le coup vous pourrez dire indigènes là
elles ont aucun mot par exemple fossiles
ça se dit aman temps mohammad à la hâte
au lac à la m à la battini et encore je
fais pas les clics
tout ça c'est un fossile est en dessous
là c'est un os de dinosaures
donc bon je vais même pas essayé un là
pour le coup c'est limite
c'est limite une insulte de m'entendre
prononcer ça généralement je demande à
un étudiant zoulou parce que c'est du
zoulou je demande à un étudiant si je
demande s'il ya un zoulou dans la salle
est généralement il lève la main et là
je leur dis est ce que tu peux prononcer
ça parce que moi je vais pas essayer
c'est une insulte les étudiants m'ont eu
même dit qu'il préférait ne pas
m'entendre le prononcé que de me voir
essayer donc apparemment c'est un vrai
massacre quand je le dis et donc le
registre fossile maintenant troisième
définition le registre fossile donc
c'est le registre de toute la vie
ancienne et de son évolution à travers
les âges géologiques
donc c'est l'ensemble des fossiles qu'on
retrouve fossilisé dans l'est dans les
temps géologiques
donc voilà les trois définitions l'écho
3 grande définition
qu'est ce que la paléontologie c'est la
science des fossiles qu'est ce qu'un
fossile une trace de vie préservé dans
la roche ou même d'activité de vie
préservé dans la roche et le registre
fossile c'est l'ensemble de tous ces
fossiles
donc maintenant la distinction qui pique
la distinction entre paléontologie et
archéologie donc archéologie d'ailleurs
ça s'explique le coût du hameau
s'applique aussi archéologie donc là
c'est plaît à l'américaine mais on peut
aussi les plaies à la british
c'est donc l'archéologie c'est l'étude
et le produit culturel
donc techniquement
ceci est du registre de l'archéologie
cela est du registre de la paléontologie
pourtant toutes les deux sont des traces
d'activités d'homo sapiens ceci reste
une trace de l'activité d'homo sapiens
et homo sapiens qui a produit cet
artefact donc c'est un outil en pierre
ces homo sapiens qui a produit cet
artefact et pourtant on ne considère pas
ça comme étant du domaine de la
paléontologie en deux on considère ça
comme étant du domaine de l'archéologie
donc là pour le coup ça vous ça ferait
presque de l'archéologie un sous domaine
de la paléontologie mais là on parle
évidemment de l'archéologie très
ancienne de l'archéologie paléolithique
évidemment
l'archéologie moderne si vous vous
occupez des châteaux médiévaux je veux
dire typiquement vous n'êtes pas une
sous discipline de la paléontologie
évidemment mais tout simplement parce
que ce n'est pas fossilisées mais là
pour le coup c'est un produit de
l'activité humaine donc techniquement on
peut appeler ça un fossile et pourtant
c'est du domaine de l'archéologie et ça
par contre c'est certainement l'individu
donc c'est un homo sapiens enfin ces
homo heidelbergensis ou homo et lé pays
qui vivait à l'époque du middle stone
age donc de l'âge de pierre moyens et
qui fabriquait des outils comme ça mais
lui par contre ce crâne
il est du registre de la paléontologie
parce que c'est la trace de vie elle
même c'est pas la trace de là c'est pas
un artefact produit de la culture
humaine donc là et là ça devient
compliqué et c'est là où l'on voit la
limite de ces définitions je veux dire
on va pas on va pas faire comme s'il y
avait des définitions bien carrées et
qu'il fallait les suivre non on va tout
de suite joué cartes sur table ces
définitions sont poreuses et là par
exemple vous avez un homo sapiens donc
je crois que c'est celui c'est un homo
sapiens qui a été trouvé en palestine
qui est très bien préservés et vous
voyez donc c'est une tombe donc la tombe
elle même est un produit culturel
mais le squelette lui-même est un
produit n'est pas un produit culturel
donc c'est une trace de vie donc le
squelette lui-même est du domaine de la
paléontologie la tombe
un l est du domaine de l'archéologie et
c'est juste pour dire que voilà bon en
général ça ça va finir dans les mains
d'un archéologue de toute façon puisque
la tombe l'ensemble de la sépulture est
du domaine de l'archéologie mais voilà
c'est juste pour dire que c'est très
poreux évidemment et qui a pas de de
limites
extra solide et pour vous et pour vous
montrer ça on va faire un petit un petit
jeu après qui va qui va illustrer tout
ça donc la paléontologie il ya un bon
moyen généralement d un moyen qui
marchent à 95% des cas évidemment là je
vais vous montrer les 5% qui se
chevauchent mais à 95% des cas la
paléontologie c'est tout entre 3,8
milliards
année et 3 3 millions d'années et
l'archéologie ça concerne que les 3,3
millions d'années restant ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya pas de paléontologie dans
3,3 millions d'années restant mais ça
veut dire que l'archéologie son terrain
de jeu il est là c'est à dire les
premiers artefacts dytique 3,3 millions
d'années les premiers outils en gros qui
sont trouvés au kenya 3,3 millions
d'années donc ça commence là en fait un
d'archéologie ça commence tout près du
zéro là et tout ça tout ça
ici c'est le terrain de jeu du
paléontologue et il n'y a aucune chance
d'avoir de l'archéologie là dedans donc
c'est juste pour ça marche comme utilisé
à 95% le truc c'est que les 3,3 millions
d'années qui reste là ils sont très
riches en fossiles on y trouve des
risées des fossiles d'humains de
mammifères de tout ce que vous voulez de
requins donc ils sont très riches en
fossiles donc ils sont toujours très
riche en paléontologie savent eux c'est
pas parce que là le registre
archéologiques commence à 3,3 millions
d'années que le registre paléontologique
s'arrête pas du tout pas qu'il ya des
faux cils
il ya de la paléontologie par contre si
vous êtes à plus de 3,3 millions
d'années il ya aucune chance que vous
ayez de l'archéologie voilà c'est là où
je banques
aucune notion très importante pour les
géologues que sont mes étudiants c'est
la notion de taphonomie c'est à dire
comment les fossiles se forment la
taphonomie c'est l'étude de du processus
de fossilisation donc comment les choses
deviennent fossilisés donc généralement
une fois de plus c'est un scénario à
c'est un scénario qui couvrent 80 60 à
80 % des cas généralement l'eau va avoir
une énorme importance ça va pas être un
élément décisif systématiquement comme
par exemple les fossiles préserver dans
l'ombre lie à 0 la zero intervention de
l'os et lambres qui fait tout le travail
mais dans la plupart des cas ce qui va
se passer c'est que un organisme va
mourir va être recouvert d'eau et cet ol
est importante pourquoi parce qu'elle va
ramener des sédiments
parce que la plupart des gens sont très
très au courant que l'eau est un facteur
déterminant dans la fossilisation mais
on se demande réellement pourquoi donc
là l'eau est déterminante parce qu'elle
amène avec elle des sédiments
elle amène avec elle de la terre de la
boue notamment ce qui va être très
fossilifère c'est ce qu'on appelle les
plaines d'inondation qui
occasionnellement vont recouvrir tous
les cadavres de la plaine avec une
énorme vague de boue et qui tout ça va
se retrouver enterré donc l'eau est un
processus naturel qui va enterrer les
organismes et c est en ce sens en étant
enterrée de cette façon alors va
commencer un processus de fossilisation
ce qu'on appelle la dia génèse qui
commencent généralement au bout de 1
milliard à 1 million d'années encore une
fois avec des variations la dia génèse
est beaucoup plus rapide dans une
fontaine pétrifiante à lhassa prend que
quelques années donc une question aussi
qu'on me pose souvent c'est combien de
temps il faut pour former un fossile bas
ça dépend de votre environnement
dans la dans la formation réelle creek
au canada au pas au canada en amérique
enfin aux états unis je veux dire le
canada ça fait partie de l'amérique donc
dans la formation réelle cru quand aux
états unis on retrouve encore de l'adn
dans les eaux donc ça veut dire que la
balle à faux le processus de
fossilisation est extrêmement lent on
retrouve encore de l'adn on retrouve
encore du collagène et pourtant les eaux
sont des autres dinosaures de 70
millions d'années à côté de ça vous
pouvez aller dans des endroits qui ont
même pas 40 millions d'années par
exemple et où là il n'y a plus une seule
trace d adn
par exemple le lutetia à paris par
exemple
donc les affleurements de lutetia à
paris vous pourrez toujours rechercher
de l'adn dans les dents dans les
coquillages y en a plus et puis à 200 km
de là dans la marne vous avez un endroit
où l'on retrouve des coquilles du même
âge du lutétien mais dans lequel la
nacre est préservé donc la nacre
normalement c'est un tissu mou ça ne se
préserve pas bah là pour le coup la
nacre et préserver donc loyer c'est
c'est très très variable ça dépend
vraiment de l'environnement de
préservation quoi c c'est extrêmement
variable et comme je vous disais ça peut
aller de quelques années si vous êtes
dans une fontaine pétrifiante ça peut
prendre juste une dizaine d'années et la
fontaine pétrifiante va pétrifié vos
organismes et laisser une trace derrière
qui sera plutôt un moulage d'ailleurs de
l'organisme que de l'organisme pétrifié
lui même mais là ce que vous voyez à
l'écran la pétrification des eaux eux
mêmes ça peut prendre plusieurs millions
d'années et même au bout de 70 millions
d'années ne pas être encore complet et
ça prend au moins et ça commence a à peu
près un million d'années
ça commence à peu près un million
d'années ça dépend beaucoup encore une
fois de l'eau s'il y a des flux d'eau
important dans la roche donc l'eau bouge
très lentement dans la roche mais elle
flux vous avez la nappe phréatique qui
monte et qui descend mais aussi la nappe
phréatique qui bouge c'est comme la
nappe phréatique c'est comme une rivière
qui s'écoule dans la roche est donc
cette eau qui s'écoule dans la rochelle
elle transporte des minéraux et ses
minéraux en fait par porosité à
l'intérieur de l'os vont remplacer l'os
en fait donc c'est une re
cristallisation
mais qui va se produire et enfin le
dernier processus c'est l'érosion et
c'est un facteur extrêmement important
l'érosion
parce que sans elle on axe on accéderait
jamais à tout ça donc les fossiles on
les trouve souvent déformée justement
parce qu'ils l'ont été parce qu'ils ont
été déformés par des processus de
formation de montagne de soulèvement des
plaques tectoniques
donc ils sont trés donc ils sont
déformés et ça ça énerve tout le monde
parce que du coup ils ont plus leur
forme originale et tout ça oui mais le
problème c'est que sans ce soulèvement
par les plaques tectoniques l'érosion
n'aurait pas lieu ces fossiles y
resteraient sous des kilomètres de roche
est tout ce qu on verrait si y'avait pas
de formation de deux chaînes de
montagnes et de collines par les
processus géologiques
notre seule chance de trouver des
fossiles bas ce serait de trouver des
fossiles très récent de da jeu d'âge
quaternaire parce que le monde serait
plat et on n'aurait que la couche
géologique la plus récente à
l'affleurement quoi sauf quand il y aura
une rivière à la limite mais c'est tout
quoi donc donc l'érosion est un facteur
déterminant aussi dans la recherche de
fossiles sans érosion pas de
il n'y a pas de ne pas exposer les
roches les plus anciennes voilà donc on
n'aurait pas accès aux fossiles les plus
anciens donc encore une fois
l'importance de l'eau puisque l'eau est
un facteur d'érosion critique
une fois de plus l'eau le vent sont des
facteurs d'érosion extrêmement important
et donc le moment où l'os se transforme
en fossiles donc là on est vraiment sûr
du vertébrés enfin sur de l'étude des
vertébrés mais évidemment ça marche
aussi avec les coquillages le moment le
plus critique de cette de ce processus
c'est le moment qu'on appelle la dia
génèse donc c'est le moment où les flux
d'eau vont remplacer le remplacer la
matière organique par la matière
minérale
donc c'est le moment où l'organique
devient minérale et c'est ça qui va
définir le fossile c'est la teneur en
minéraux à l'intérieur du fossile donc
encore une fois ça peut être très
variable
ça peut être extrêmement variable donc
il faut encore une fois garder à
l'esprit que il n'ya pas un pourcentage
de 2,2 y'a pas un pourcentage de
matières organiques remplacée par de la
roche qui nous fait dire est maintenant
c'est un fossile avant ça l'était pas
non c'est vous avez des subs fossiles
qui sont des zoos en cours de
fossilisation c'est à dire qu'ils sont
légèrement minéralisées mais ils le sont
mais ils ne sont pas tant que ça quoi
généralement si les fossiles qui datent
du quaternaire et vous avez aussi des
fossiles qui ont été minéralisée mais
qui ensuite ont été déminéralisée par
exemple dans les grottes dans les
grottes les fossiles sont minéralisée
dans la brèche par laquelle cit qui
coule dessus donc c'est un processus
très rapide pour le coup à l'échelle des
temps géologiques à une quelques
centaines de milliers d'années suffisent
à transformer un os en roche vue qui a
activement de la quatre sites qui se
dépose dessus est dedans donc de mai
après ses faux cils quand ils sont
érodées bas ils ceux des mines et
réalise la calcite disparaît donc là
vous n'avez plus les plus que de la
poussière qui tient ensemble que par les
maigres reste de minéraux qui restent à
l'intérieur donc ça voilà faut garder un
esprit ouvert avec ses définitions
évidemment
alors là on va pouvoir commencer le jeu
de est ce que c'est de la paléontologie
ou est ce que c'est de l'archéologie
donc on commence avec ses petits ces
petits poissons donc là je voulais ce je
vous laisse débattre entre vous donc ces
petits poissons ils sont ils sont
écrasés contre la roche n'a pas vraiment
besoin d'être un paléontologue pour voir
que c'est des poissons il ya du tissus
mous préserver c'est très joli mais est
ce que c'est un fossile ou est-ce que
c'est pas un fossile
ah bah c'est pas est ce que c'est un
fossile ou pas c est ce que c'est du
registre de l'archéologie ou est-ce que
c'est du registre de la paléontologie
donc vous avez la date ici de 170
millions d'années donc vous pouvez
revenir en arrière sur le court et voir
et voir dans quelle catégorie sa tombe
voilà ceci est un crâne de dinosaures et
airaudo taurus 200 millions d'années
pareil est-ce qu'on est dans le registre
de la paléontologie ou de l'archéologie
vous pouvez mettre les réponses en
commentaire ça pourrait être marrant je
mettrais un petit pouce bleus si vous
avez tout bon et puis si vous n'avez pas
tout bon et ben y aura pas de petits
pouces bleus voilà je mets pas des
petits pouces vers le bas parce que
parce que c'est pas gentil les pouces
vers le bas faut arrêter de mettre des
pouces vers le bas ça ça brise le coeur
des gens donc si vous avez tout bon je
mettrais un pouce vers le haut si vous
ne voyez pas un petit pouce vers le haut
c'est probablement que vous n'avez pas
tout bon je lis la plupart des
commentaires donc
donc si vous ne voyez pas de pouce ça
c'est certainement que je les lui et que
vous n'avez pas tout bon et qu'il faut
refaire donc voilà donc sept empreintes
de dinosaures en prennent de
tyrannosaurus rex 70 millions d'années
s'agit-il
étant du domaine de la paléontologie ou
de l'archéologie à à un mammouth congelé
donc c'est pas un fossile mais est-ce
que c'est du domaine de la paléontologie
ou de l'archéologie on en a parlé
donc vous pouvez répondre
wray ceci n'est pas un fossile ceci est
la momie de ramsès 2 alors s'agit-il
est-on du domaine de l'archéologie ou
étant du domaine de la paléontologie
bonne question
alors ici c'est une de nos étudiantes
moting et elle tient un petit crâne
linguistique et phallus de 257 millions
d'années s'agit-il de ce fossile est il
du domaine de l'archéologie ou de la
paléontologie
sachant que sachant que moting le tient
dans sa main
est ce que le fait que maintiennent que
moting qu'un homo sapiens tiennent un
fossile dans sa main changes le domaine
de compétence requiert qui érode qui qui
est nécessaire pour examiner ce fossile
la bonne la bonne grosse question
ce crâne de babouins ce crâne de bain
un qui a encore un petit peu de viande
comme vous pouvez le voir est il du
domaine de la paléontologie ou de
l'archéologie
peut-être qu'il ya un piège
excuse 3,7 millions d'années donc là
c'est little foot little foot est il du
domaine de l'archéologie ou de la
paléontologie
et enfin on va terminer avec un gros
piège c'est au seo qui ont été taillés
en outils alors en tant qu'outil
sont-ils du domaine de la paléontologie
ou de l'archéologie
maintenant vous avez vous voyez que la
lettre a changé on est passé de y agit
en tant qu'os sont-ils du domaine de
l'archéologie ou de la paléontologie
sachant qu'ils ont 20 mille ans celui là
c'est un piège voilà donc j'attends vos
réponses dans les commentaires
on va bien voir si c'est si le jeu vous
intéresse évidemment maintenant on passe
aux différents types de fossilisation
puisque comme je voulais dit je vous ai
présenté le type de fossilisation le
plus courant celui où un squelette ou un
organisme quelconque laisser ces parties
dures et les parties durent était
enfouie grâce à l'eau et étaient
transformés en roche grâce encore une
fois à l'eau mais c'est pas le seul type
de fossilisation qui existe il ya
plusieurs types de fossilisation on va
pas tous les voir en détail évidemment
mais c'est bon de les connaître quand
même donc premièrement c'est le
remplacement donc c'est celui qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que les
tissus durs donc le remplacement c'est
aussi ce qu'on appelle la paire
minéralisation ou la substitution
je rentre pas dans le détail des deux
processus qui sont légèrement différents
c'est vraiment la paire minéralisation
c'est le tissu qui se transforme en
roche la substitution c'est le tissu qui
est remplacée par de la roche c'est au
final c'est du remplacement c'est à dire
que le le l'organisme enfin ce qui
restait de l'organisme conserve sa forme
mais mais au lieu de que ce soit du
tissus organiques maintenance et du
tissu cdu c'est plus du tissu ces deux
là c'est du minéral donc
généralement ce sont les tissus durs qui
subissait un remplacement ou une permet
un remplacement ou une paire
minéralisation généralement sur les
tissus durs quand donc comme les dents
ici vous voyez les eaux donc là vous
avez des ossements et des dents sur ce
mets aux eaux russes et vous avez le
bois le bois est un tissu dur est peut
être remplacé donc c'est typiquement la
vous avez du bois silicifiées donc là
tout et tout et dans le monde c'est le
bois qui a été transformé en silice ou
remplacés par de la silice donc c'est
les tissus dure généralement qui
subissent ce genre de fossilisation donc
c'est exactement ce que je vous ai
montré plutôt et c'est vraiment l'eau
qui dans ce cas là va va jouer un rôle
clé dans la dissolution est la
dissolution du tissu de base et le son
remplacement par dépôt d'une nouvelle
d'un nouveau minéral
donc c'est un processus qui est très
complexe qui est très simple à
comprendre mais qui est très complexe
dans le détail on se demande on en vient
à se demander même comment ça tient en
fait comment la morphologie et préservé
par ce processus bourse est simplement
parce que le flot d'eau c'est pas
évidemment c'est pas un jet d'eau au
karcher c'est un flot d'eau qui est très
très lent et très très riches en minéral
donc en fait il ya le remplacement au
niveau moléculaire j'ai envie de dire il
est presque instantanée il et il n'ya
pas de déplacements il n'y a pas
beaucoup de déplacements par contre vu
que vous avez ce flot d'eau qui remplace
le minéral en même temps que vous avez
des mouvements tectoniques
c'est pour ça que les fossiles se
déforme c'est parce que du coup ce
remplacement a lieu en même temps qu'un
mouvement donc du coup ça ça déforme
vous fossiles comme si c'est comme s'ils
étaient fondus en fait mais c'est
justement parce que la fossilisation est
en cours que ça arrive
les moulages et les alors les moulages
et les moules
donc il ya les moules voici une moule
un fossile de moules et ce fossile de
moules on voit son moule et envoie son
moulage j'ai pas pris le meilleur
exemple en anglais en anglais ça pose
pas de problème parce qu'on appelle
jusqu'à 1 bivalves alors bain donc voici
à bivalves voici le moule du bivalves et
voici le moulage du bibal
donc ça c'est le moule de la surface
externe
et ça ce le moulage donc c'est là le là
contre empreinte si vous voulez de ce
truc là
donc ce ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
moule ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
moulage donc ici pareil ça marche aussi
avec les vertébrés voyez ici vous avez
le moule de la boîte crânienne est ici
vous avez le moulage de la boîte
crânienne et là on voit ce moulage en
fait c'est du remplissage sédimentaires
comme ici vous voyez vous aviez la
coquille et cette coquille a été rempli
par du sédiment qui a donné le moulage
et là c'est pareil vous aviez la boîte
crânienne
vous avez un remplissage sédimentaires
qui est de la calcite vous voyez les
cristaux de calcite ça c'est l'autre
côté ça c'est le creux c'est l'endocrâne
donc le moulage de la qualité du cerveau
là vous avez le côté où vous voyez les
petites veines et tout ça qui sont
préservés et là c'est l'autre côté
l'intérieur ou ce que vous voyez c'est
la calcite en fait qui a remplacé qui a
rempli la cavité de l'endocrâne donc on
voit les cristaux de calcite à
l'intérieur donc ça c'est le moule et ça
c'est le moulage dans ce pardon voilà
dieu je me trompe
ça c'est le moulage de la boîte
crânienne ici et ça c'est le moule donc
le moulant du de la boîte crânienne
c'est le crâne lui-même donc le crâne et
préserver au moins à l'avant la face et
à l'arrière vous n'avez que le moulage
donc un animal dans l'ombre
techniquement c'est un moule puisqu'il
n'y a rien c'est une bulle à l'intérieur
mais c'était c'est une bulle qui est
extrêmement bien qui est extrêmement
bien préservé qui extraient extrêmement
finement détaillé mais ça reste un moule
c'est pas un corps en fait de fossiles
comme on a pu le voir dans leur
emplacement leur emplacement c'est le
remplacement c'est vraiment le cas
de l'objet qui est qui et préservés
alors que là il ya juste la surface qui
est préservée en fait y'a rien à
l'intérieur et vous voyez et et ça c'est
pour vous illustrer que les moules
moulage peuvent être de différentes
natures donc enfin le moulage en
fonction du remplissage du moule
peut-être fed par exemple de matériaux
précieux comme ici il peut être en
émeraude alors ce petit coquillage là
qui nous vient d'amérique du sud est en
émeraude d'ailleurs je n'ai pas dit tout
à l'heure mais le remplacement peut
aussi se faire en matériaux précieux ou
semi précieux comme l'opal par exemple
donc tout dépend en fait de ce que vous
avez dans la flotte qui arrive quoi donc
là c'est pareil ça dépend tout dépend de
du contenu de la flotte qui qui remplit
votre votre petit votre moule
si si cette eau et hydrothermales et
contient les bons éléments les bons les
bons rapports de silice et de et de tous
et des atomes qu'il faut quoi je suis
pas chimiste alors je vais pas me lancer
là dedans mais voilà s'il contient si
cette eau contient ce qu'il faut à la
température qu'il faut à la pression
qu'il faut vous pouvez finir avec des
moulages qui conte des moulages fait de
matériaux précieux comme de l'émeraude
par exemple je connais pas d'exemple de
fossiles en or mais en théorie ça
devrait être possible mais comme je le
disais la dans les moules
il ya cette particularité que vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin d'eau le
lambres lambres en lui même se solidifie
alors il va se transformer en fossiles
lambres lui-même va se transformer en
fossiles par les processus qu'on a vu
plus haut par contre par contre le
fossile de l'animal ici qui nous
intéresse lui sont fausses il s'est
formé directement dans l'ombre
donc il ya l'eau n'a pas joué de rôle
direct sur la fossilisation de l'animal
par contre il va peut-être jouer un rôle
dans la formation de lambres après il ya
ce pari lambres c'est tout un univers
donc on va pas trop se lancer là dedans
mais voilà c'est ça qu'il faut par
contre dès fois ça arrive
il ya aussi sale par exemple au cul lui
dans ta vie ce donc le fameux petit truc
qu'on croyait que c'était le plus petit
oiseau dinosaures du monde
et finalement c'est juste un lézard
lambres contient le squelette donc là là
c'est un mélange en fait de la
fossilisation dans l'ombre et de la
fossilisation par emplacement
encore une fois les définitions que je
vous donne ne sont sont des définitions
humaine fait par les hommes pour les
hommes
enfin peu fait par des chercheurs pour
les chercheurs donc encore une fois
c'est pour eux c'est très très poreux et
vous n'aurez aucun mal à trouver à un
fossile qui tombe dans plusieurs
catégories
typiquement on va voir ça avec la une
des catégories qui est je crois à celle
là la catégorie des traces fossiles qui
devrait normalement être numérotées 4
mais bref d'abord les empreintes mais on
va voir qu'avec la catégorie suivante il
ya beaucoup de porosité donc les
empreintes les empreintes c'est juste
voilà ap la tipp et et puis voilà c'est
tout c'est c'est un fin film de carbone
ou d'autre chose d'ailleurs qui se
retrouvent préserver en deux dimensions
donc c'est par exemple le cas des
fossiles de burgès comme ceux cette auto
ya ici que j'ai eu l'insigne honneur de
voir à burges et c'est le cas de ces
feuilles de glossop terrisse ici donc
c'est vraiment juste et des fois même le
film de carbone par mail est l'empreinte
du film de carbone et dans ce cas là on
est presque à la frontière avec le voyez
le moulage le moule et le moulage et
puis vous avez les traces fossiles ou là
c'est la teuf
parce qu'avec les traces fossiles vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup de choses donc
les traces fossiles c'est toutes les
formes de traces d'activité c'est à dire
que vous n'avez pas de corps fossiles
techniquement il n'ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de dos
il n'y a pas de ya pas de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler de deux cadavres à
l'intérieur voilà c'est juste la trace
de l'activité donc ça peut être des
faits cesse donc ce qu'on appelle les
coprolithe vous avez des empreintes vous
avez les terriers vous avez les d eux
sont considérés comme des traces
fossiles mais des fois elle est des fois
justement ils contiennent des squelettes
et alors là on est à la frontière entre
la traces fossiles et le remplacement si
vous avez un squelette à l'intérieur
pareil pour les terriers les terriers
ici vous avez des terriers comme celui
là qui ne contiennent rien et vous avez
des terriers qui vont contenir des
fossiles qui vont avoir une chambre
terminal qui contient un fossile et dans
ce cas là bas vous avez une traces
fossiles plus un remplacement
donc c'est là où je dis que vous avez de
la porosité entre les définitions donc
les oeufs et les nie évidemment vous
avez des fois plusieurs the préserver
ensemble pour former des nids donc là
vous avez une crotte de t-rex une crotte
à tilbury un t-rex tout simplement parce
qu'elle est trouvé dans les couches où
on trouve tyrannosaurus rex
elle est de très grande taille d'une
taille qui peut qui correspond plus
grand prédateur locale tyrannosaurus rex
et elle contient des eaux et ses eaux
indique qu'elle appartienne à un grand
prédateur donc le plus grand prédateur à
cet endroit là il à ce moment là c'est
t-rex et du coup elles contiennent de
l'os donc encore une fois il ya eu
remplacement il ya eu le remplacement
donc cette traces fossiles contient des
rangs des fossiles de remplacement vous
avez les empreintes évidemment donc la
très jolie empruntent les en pagne qui
sont très intéressantes et d'ailleurs
les traces fossiles en général sont
intéressantes parce qu'en fait ce
qu'elles ont en commun donc justement
vous pourriez vous demander
mais du coup c'est quoi la différence
entre un fossile de remplacement une
traces fossiles comment comment on trace
la limite entre les deux puisque ces
traces fossiles peuvent contenir des
fossiles rang de remplacement à la
limite elle est au niveau 2 qui l'a fait
et comment ces traces fossiles sont
faites par des organismes
quand ils sont en vie
et pas quand ils sont morts c'est la
différence avec les fossiles de
remplacement les fossiles de
remplacement c'est systématiquement des
organismes morts ou qui sont morts très
rapidement avant de fossilisés les
traces de vie enfin les traces fossiles
sont des traces de vie c'est un
tyrannosaure rex qui a fait ce cas cas
c'est un tyrannosaure rex vivant qui a
fait ce qu à castin tira c'est un
dinosaure vivant qui a fait ses
empreintes et c'est un petit sino dont
tu vivant qui a fait ce terrier fossiles
d'ailleurs vous voyez les petite crête
là que vous voyez en fait ce sont les
contres empreintes des griffes du synode
honte quand ils gratter la surface donc
c'est pour ça que ça fait un peu pour ça
que ça fait de loeb
en fait c'est parce que vous avez le
trou qui a été creusée de chaque côté
par par chaque bras en fait vous avez un
lob d'un côté un lob de l'autre pour
chaque coup de griffe qui a été donné si
vous comptez à chaque fois il ya quatre
griffe qui ont qui ont donné des coups
de griffes sur le côté donc ça c'est un
très très très jolie foxy très très
jolie fossiles donc voilà c'est des
animaux vivants fins et des organismes
vivants qui font ces traces fossiles pas
des organismes mort ou en train de
mourir et c'est ça la grosse différence
entre une traces fossiles est un fossile
classique donc c'est littéralement des
fossiles vivants
et puis la dernière catégorie de
fossiles ou lassé peut avoir de tous les
types de fossiles qu'on a déjà présenté
mais qui est unifié par une seule et un
seul et unique caractère c'est les
microfossiles et le caractère qui les
unit c'est qu'ils sont tout petits
voilà y'a pas plus à chercher que ça je
veux dire ils peuvent se former par
paire minéralisation part ça peut être
des petites emprunte ça peut être tout
ce que vous voulez au final les
microfossiles c'est des tout-petits
fossiles points donc encore une fois
c'est des définitions fait par les
chercheurs pour les chercheurs c'est
vraiment faut bien conserver le comté
arbitraire de ces fossiles et certains
ne sont même pas totalement fossilisés
un les pollens ici que vous voyez la
raison pour laquelle ils sont
transparents et est légèrement jaunâtre
c'est parce que ce que vous voyez c'est
encore de la protéine c'est la protéine
hla ce propos lénine on appelle ça la ce
propos lénine kinki qui est très très
dur c'est une protéine qui est
extrêmement résistante et qui peut
résister pendant des millions d'années
sans se désagréger en fait donc ses
pollens la techniquement ne sont même
pas des fossiles c'est encore de l'as
propos lénine qui est préservée
d'ailleurs on les la façon dont on les
prépare c'est qu'on les balances dans
l'acide en balance la roche dans l'acide
et on récupère ce qui flotte en gros
c'est plus compliqué que ça évidemment
ami ami paléobotaniste qui me regarde et
ne vous énervez pas je sais que c'est
plus compliqué que ça mais voilà en gros
les balances dans l'acide on récupère ce
qui flotte et ce qui flotte c'est ce qui
n'est pas minérale en fait et c'est pour
ça qu'on arrive à récupérer ces grains
de pollen parce qu'ils ne sont pas miner
ron et du coup la cidh ne leur fait rien
mais évidemment vous avez les
foraminifères qui eux sont fossilisés
est qui et qui tous et tous sont des
indicateurs des marqueurs
biostratigraphie extrêmement important
plus donc non seulement c'est une
catégorie qui est un peu flottante mais
en plus c'est une catégorie qui est
hyper importante du point de vue
géologique et stratigraphique donc
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de ce que
c'est qu'un fossile
au final après cette introduction bas
on peut dire que généralement c'est des
tissus durs mais pas toujours des fois
il ya des tissus mous on peut dire que
généralement ça prend au moins un
million d'années
mais enfin que le processus de
fossilisation de dia génèse prend à peu
près au moins un million d'années pour
transformer la matière organique en
matière minérale mais pas toujours et
assez souvent enfin quelques fois plus
souvent que qu'on pourrait l'imaginer et
bien on a des préservation de tissus
mous et dans le cas des vertébrés dont
on appelle ça enfin ça peut être des
vertébrés aussi des invertébrés dans le
cas de burgès par exemple et dans ce cas
là on a ce qu'on appelle de la guerche
tâtonne donc c'est le mot allemand pour
préservation exceptionnelles je sais pas
exactement comment ça se traduit pour
être tout à fait honnête c'est juste
voilà les préservation la guerre staaten
seller préservation vous avez vous avez
tous qui est conservé en fait alors
après vous avez différents types de la
gorge tâtonne encore une fois on va pas
ce qu'on va pas plonger là dedans mais
vous avez l'élagueur staaten qui
préserve les eaux en articulation vous
avez la gorge d'athènes qui préserve les
tissus mous vous avez voilà vous avez
différents types de la guerche tête mais
mais voilà en général quand vous avez
une préservation qui est exceptionnel
vous avez un la gorge stats
selon certaines définitions du la gorge
tâte le site d'angeac charente est à la
gorge tâte parce que les eaux sont
peut-être pas préservée en articulation
on a peut-être pas de tissus mous mais
la façon dont les eaux sont préservés
ils sont vraiment super bien préservés
voilà donc il ya pareil il ya tout un
panel de définition pour la gorge stats
mais globalement quand une conservation
est exceptionnellement bonne on appelle
ça un d'ailleurs je tâte et quand vous
avez de l'adn typiquement donc si vous
avez de l'adn comme par exemple c'est le
cas on retrouve de l'adn fin on retrouve
de l'adn par exemple dans l'est dans les
glaces de sibérie on pourrait appeler ça
on peut appeler les glaces de sibérie
l'élagueur stadt alors pourtant même que
c'est même pas du fossile voyez c'est où
c'est un peu la fête les définitions
c'est toujours pareil c'est très
compliqué à gérer
évidemment je ne pars pas dans tous ses
points de détail quand je suis avec mes
étudiants en première année là c'est
juste parce qu'on est entre nous et
voilà je vous on a déjà on a déjà eu
ensemble des cours de niveau master on
m'a dépassé ce niveau où on se contente
des définitions sens sans parler de
leurs limites quoi je le dire donc voilà
donc là par exemple le quart ou
d'afrique du sud n'est pas
universellement considérée comme l
allure stats et pourtant on y trouve ce
fossile donc c'est alice roseaux russe
et se lisse trop russe vous pouvez voir
à de la peau d'ailleurs ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec ce bistrot aux russes
c'est que cette peau fossilisés n'a pas
de poils ce qui pour un synapses id
enfin pour un pour un terreau abside
d'ailleurs dans ce cas là donc un
reptile malien est plutôt surprenant
mais il n'y a pas de poils sur la peau
de ce bistrot urgent aux dons qu'il
avait la peau nue comme un petit cochon
comme un petit cochon voilà et donc
pourtant pourtant le carreau n'est pas
considérée comme à la gorge stats
bon voilà c'est la grande magie des
définitions
alors on ne
1 on ne peut pas avoir une introduction
faire une introduction à la
paléontologie sans au moins un moment
tremper les pieds dans la taxonomie et
ça c'est une chose que j'aime pas du
tout parce que parce que c'est la
taxonomie c'est compliqué c'est la
classification des espèces à la
taxonomie pour ceux qui savent pas la
classification des espèces c'est très
très compliqué c'est très très subjectif
et au final c'est ça être pas beaucoup
les étudiants c'est très utile
j'allais dire c'est pas très utile mais
si le problème c'est que c'est très
utile
c'est indispensable de connaître la
taxonomie et c'est indispensable de
connaître les limites de la taxonomie
c'est aussi ça le problème et le
problème c'est que aborder les limites
de la taxonomie alors même que vous
venez de découvrir le mot taxonomie
parce que c'est le cas en première année
pour la plupart des étudiants
je rappelle qu'on est sûr d étudiant en
géologie la biologie ça ne les intéresse
pas voilà donc on est sûr d étudiant en
géologie donc la biologie ils s'en
foutent
donc quand vous leur parlez de taxonomie
déjà déjà s'ils ont tenu jusqu'à ce
niveau là du court c'est vachement bien
alors quand vous commencez à avoir parlé
de taxonomie vous leur mettez le final
punch ils sont morts donc généralement
j'essaye de simplifier sa au maximum
donc pourquoi ça s'appelle de la
taxonomie est bien parce qu'on parle
d'unité qu'on nomme des taxes ont donc
l'espèce le genre la famille
ce sont des taxons ce sont des taxes oms
chaque étage de cette de ce grand arbre
de classification est un taxon toute la
vie c'est ça le truc qui est pas un
taxon parce que c'est pas diviser enfin
que c'est que c'est pas une division à
l'intérieur de la ville mais par contre
chaque division à l'intérieur de la vie
est un taxon donc les domaines les
royaumes je sais c'est bizarre d'appeler
ça des royaumes les fuit l'homme les
classes tout ça ce sont des tout ça ce
sont des taxes on essaie de ce sont des
petites boîtes imbriqués les uns les
unes dans les autres et qui permet de
classifier des espèces donc dans un
genre comme le genre
je crois que j'ai mis des exemples après
voilà dans un genre comme le genre homo
vous allez avoir plusieurs espèces comme
par exemple homo erectus et homo habilis
homo neandertalensis homo sapiens
l'espèce est généralement l'unité de
base mais vous pouvez avoir donc ce
qu'on appelle des variétés chez les
plantes est ce qu'on appelle des races
chez les animaux ou des sous-espèces
aussi on peut parler deux sous-espèces
chez les animaux mais généralement
l'espèce est considérée comme l'unité de
base voilà avec des définitions qui
peuvent varier mais là je vous renvoie à
ma vidéo sur doit-on dire homo sapiens
et néandertal n 6 donc j'essaierai de me
rappeler qu'il faut que je vous la met
en définition en oui en descriptions
celle là parce que parce que je risque
d'oublier si j'ai oublié rappelé le mois
dans les commentaires de m la vidéo sur
homo sapiens et néandertal et ciné en
der taelen 6 pour connaître exactement
comment ça marche le système de de
comment on fait pour nommer une espèce
et surtout de connaître les limites
encore une fois de les multiples
définitions de l'espèce parce qu'il y en
a plusieurs
eux ce qu'ils doivent savoir c'est qu'en
gros il ya des taxons et qu'en gros on
les divise entre les taxons de haut rang
à savoir lors de la classe le fuit
l'homme est au dessus et l'état les
taxes sont de rang deux rangs plus bas
donc la famille le genre l'espèce
globalement je ne joue qu'avec la
famille le genre est l'espèce j'essaye
de de toucher le moins possible aux
ordres mais en gros quand je leur donne
quand je leur donne un ordre donc les
carnivores à et les primates par exemple
ce sont deux ordres
j'essaye de j'essaie je leur dis juste
que c'est un taxon de haut rang voilà et
quand je leur donne la famille le genre
l'espèce là par exemple là par contre je
le redis essayer quand même d'être à
l'aise avec ça les familles généralement
ça finit par idée
donc c'est comme ça qu'on les distingue
des ordres qui finissent généralement
par a enfin des taxons de haut rang
d'ailleurs mais les familles finissent
pas idée alors que les tak sont de haut
rang finissent généralement par un an
sauf primates évidemment parce qu'il
faut toujours faut toujours une
exception mais voilà donc les taxes sont
de haut rang finissent par un hâle et
actions de rang inférieur finissent par
idées ou par autre chose voilà
généralement les espèces finissent par
un us sauf homo sapiens encore une fois
encore une exception mais généralement
les espèces finissent paru sous hommes
femmes rech
c'est c'est ce que j'essaye de le redire
mais après voilà faut qu'il soit
relativement à l'aise avec ce système de
taxonomie comme je le redis au moins
pour savoir de quoi on parle quand après
on parle d'évolution des espèces puisque
la suite de tout ça ça va être
l'évolution des espèces donc il faut
quand même qu'ils aient une idée
voilà de quoi sapin donc voila comme
j'ai dit ça va très très vite
ça va très très vite la taxonomie donc
c'est les classifications sont
arbitraires elles sont faits par les
gens et fort contre venione cela donc ce
que j'ai écris c'est vraiment c'est par
les gens pour être pratique donc ya pas
il n'y a pas à être un grand comment
dirais-je yade il ya des gens qui sont
capables de faire des grands cas de
d'erreur de classification mais les deux
erreurs de classifier enfin comment dire
on va prendre un exemple tout simple
voilà on va plutôt prendre un exemple
plutôt que d'essayer d'expliquer c'est
prenez par exemple lors enfin le super
ordre d'été rapide donc terap sida il
est lui même contenu dans un ensemble
plus grand qui s'appelle les synapses
ida qu'on ne peut pas du coup appelé un
super super ordre voilà donc déjà là il
ya un problème mais l'ordre des supers
ordre des thérapies sida est contenue
dans un super super ordre ce qui
n'existe pas qui s'appelle les synapses
sida et à l'intérieur des thérapies sida
on trouve des ordres donc ses ordres ce
sont les dinos faya les biards mosuc ya
les les anneaux mode on tient les terros
faya et les six noms dont sia sachant
que les synodes honte donc les signaux
dont elle été rossés fans
sachant que les signaux dompter les
terres aussi fall ensemble forment ce
qu'on appelle les oeufs les eaux
thériault d'hondt les eaux thériault
dompte ya donc eu thériault dompte ya
c'est censé être une unité de
classification entre le super ordre et
l'ordre alors qu'est ce que c'est bonne
question et à l'intérieur des six noms
dont nokia on trouve le l'ordre des sino
guinéenne sia
on trouve enfin on trouve le sous-ordre
pardon donc à l'intérieur de l'ordre
décider si nokia on trouve le sous-ordre
je remets la bonne diapos là pour vous
suiviez on trouve le sous-ordre dessine
au ghana tia et le sous-ordre des des
pro b l'omnia et à l'intérieur du souss
ordre des pros benatia on trouve ma
mallya alors si vous suivez un peu là le
schéma vous avez l'ordre des sino dont
tu vous avez un sous-ordre qui s'appelle
les pros baignade donc là si on descend
encore d'un cran et à la famille
là les mammifères c'est pas juste une
famille
les mammifères à l'intérieur vous avez
vous avez quatre fous vous attend du
coup est ce que ces désordres est-ce que
c'est des classes n'ont du coup mme hamm
alias est censé être une classe voilà en
plus elle est là ma malien donc mme hamm
alias est censé être une classe sauf que
cette classe est fait partie d'un
sous-ordre d'été rapide
est ce que ça vous suffit ou est-ce
qu'il faut que j'explique plus pourquoi
la taxonomie c'est arbitraire et j'aime
pas j'aime vraiment pas tromper là
dedans
vous voyez vous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi j'utilise juste rang élevé rang
inférieur à ce que autrement on patauge
pas touche c'est une horreur c'est une
horreur et et vous faut en plus vous
imaginez que tout ce beau monde fait
partie des tétrapodes à les tétrapodes
qui est censé être soit fuit l'homme
soient une super classe j'en sais rien
mais les tétrapodes c'est pareil c'est
juste un sous-groupe des sarko pts est
rien
et sarko t'es rien c'est juste un ordre
parmi les poissons
donc voilà c'est un peu le problème des
classifications c'est qu'elles sont pas
faites pour ça sent pas fait pour être
manipulés de cette façon de donc
donc il faut connaître il faut savoir il
faut être relativement à l'aise au moins
avec comme je vous ai dit les ordres
supérieurs et les ordres inférieurs et à
l'intérieur des ordres inférieur au
moins savoir famille genre espèces mais
non c'est trop compliqué donc voila et
l'espèce donc la limite c'est l'inter
fécondité
finalement je la donne quand même cette
définition mais c'est juste pour la
contraste est justement c'est la
définition de l'espèce moderne pour
pouvoir la contrasté avec la définition
d'une espèce fossile
encore une fois je ne donne cette
définition des espèces modernes que pour
dire la limite c'est l'inter fait qu'on
dit et donc la capacité de deux espèces
à faire un petit qui lui même soit
fertile donc par exemple ici vous avez
un zombie qui est un zèbre et un âne
dont 15 et bran zone je sais pas comment
on dit en français en anglais aiment
bien le nom anglais zone qui c'est un
mélange de zebra et de dongqi donc ce
zèbre donc qui il est il est pas fait
qu'on normalement bien que chez les
zèbres et les ânes des fois on aidé des
hybrides qu'ils soient fécond mais bref
normalement c'est là que se trouve la
limite entre les espèces modernes le
problème c'est que de toute façon cette
limite on ne peut pas l'appliquer aux
fossiles puisque on ne saura jamais si
les espèces dont on parle chez les
fossiles sont sont un terreau fécond ou
pas donc on va juste considérer pour les
fossiles que de deux individus
appartiennent à une espèce séparé s'ils
sont suffisamment différent du point de
vue anatomique et dans le cas du zèbre
et de l'âne les différences anatomiques
sont ténues mais elle existe un peu
quand même
donc on en ferait on en ferait quand
même deux espèces si c'était des espèces
aussi c'était des faux cils on en ferait
quand même deux espèces un exemple
typique encore une fois je vous renvoie
à ma vidéo sur nés en homo sapiens
neanderthalensis c'est justement homo
sapiens et homo néandertalienne
les deux sont considérés comme des
espèces bien séparées par les
paléontologues parce que
morphologiquement y'a pas à tortiller du
cul
ils sont séparés par contre on sait
qu'ils étaient interféron donc d'un
point de vue de la définition de
l'espèce moderne on devrait elle est
considérée comme la même espèce et il
n'y a pas de ceux ya pas de bonne
solution
encore une fois je l'expliquent avec
homo sapiens dans l'autre vidéo
il n'y a pas de solution magique qui
marche à tous les coups à partir du
moment où vous avez plusieurs
définitions possibles et qui se valent
autant les unes que les autres parce que
je le rappelle la définition des espèces
modernes ne peut pas s'appliquer aux
espèces fossiles est inapplicable donc
la définition que j'utilise la limite où
la limite est la morphologie c'est la
meilleure définition de l'espèce chrome
est pour l'appliquer au registre fossile
ya pas de meilleure définition que ça
donc il ya toutes les définitions se
valent toutes les définitions leurs
avantages et leurs inconvénients et à
partir du moment où vous avez n
supérieur à une définition
ben c'est fini c'est le bordel
voilà donc on va quand même essayer de
voir on va quand même essayer de calquer
le plus possible ce concept d' espèce
fossile au concept d'espèces moderne en
comparant justement si la variabilité
entre les deux individus en question
enfin en comparant si les variations de
les variations morphologiques entre les
deux individus sont équivalents à des
variations morphologiques on verrait
chez deux espèces modernes mais par
exemple le zèbre et l'âne ne sont pas
deux espèces séparées aussi bien
séparées morphologiquement que le son le
chimpanzé est l'homme par exemple le
chimpanzé et l'homme morphologiquement
y'a pas à tortiller le zèbre et l'âne
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de faire
la différence entre les deux voilà donc
et pourtant tout ça c'est considéré
comme deux espèces différentes
enfin pour le coup le zèbre el weleily
zèbres et lan ce sont deux espèces
différentes du genre et cus et alors que
l'homme et le chimpanzé ce sont aussi
deux espèces différentes alors ils font
pas partie du même genre justement parce
qu'ils sont très différents
anatomiquement mais voilà la différence
génétique entre les deux est pas
gigantesque non plus donc c'est c'est un
débat interminable
c'est un débat interminable faut juste
savoir que voilà la définition de
l'espèce il faut savoir faut être
confortable avec l'idée que de toute
façon c'est faut être à l'aise avec les
rangs taxonomique il faut être à l'aise
avec le fait que ses rangs taxonomique
ne valent pas grand-chose biologiquement
voilà c'est c'est faut que ce soit très
clair dans la tête le truc comme je la
phrase de conclusion généralement avec
ça c'est la seule chose qui doit être
clair dans votre tête à ce niveau là
c'est que on va utiliser des rangs
taxonomique qui veulent pas dire grand
chose voilà c'est en gros c'est ça qui
sont susceptibles de changer de varier
en fonction de la littérature que vous
lisez pas ce que ça aussi ça va c'est
important pour les étudiants de de
savoir comment interpréter la
littérature notamment comment
interpréter les contradictions entre les
différentes sources puisque tous les
tous les livres qu'ils vont pouvoir
consulter ne vont pas forcément dire la
même chose il ya beaucoup de livres
justement qui vont vous dire que les
signaux dont tu c'est un ordre
et il ya des livres qui vont vous dire
que les mammifères s'éteint c'est un
fils homme ou une classe et comment vous
réconcilier le fait que les mammifères
c'est une classe alors qu'il s'agit d'un
sous groupe des six lots dont un qui est
un ordre
ben voila tu vois ça c'est ça que les
études c'est ça qui est important pour
les étudiants c'est de comprendre que
c'est pas un problème en fait c'est
juste pas un problème ça a été créé par
convenance par juste juste pour être
utilisable à un instant t par des
chercheurs qui s'occupent ou dessinent
aux ventes vous des mammifères voilà
sachant que les chercheurs qui s'occupe
des deux à la fois il y en a pas tant
que ça et que il s'accommode très bien
du problème voilà en ne mentionnant pas
parce que de toute façon c'est pas un
vrai problème c'est juste un problème
qu'on a créé nous mêmes en faisant don
classification art
traire voilà après avoir bien patauger
dans la taxonomie ce n'est que de diapos
et pourtant on ya passé à une plombe
on va passer à l'étape qui intéresse
réellement les étudiants c'est comment
qu'on utilise les fossiles dans la
science et l'industrie
parce que je le rappelle nos étudiants
ils veulent travailler dans des mines
enfin dans l'industrie minière pas dans
les mines elle-même évidemment vous
faites pas vous vous passez pas à
l'université pour aller piocher dans la
mine
évidemment mais mais mais l'industrie
minière elle est très friande de
fossiles normalement parce que ces
fossiles elles permettent de dater les
roches et comment elles permettent de
dater les roches grâce à ce qu'on
appelle la biostratigraphie c'est à dire
à la corrélation des roches en fonction
de leur contenu en fossiles et ça ça va
passer par certaines règles on va dire
certaines lois alors on les appelle des
lois en anglais mais j'aime pas utiliser
le mot loi parce que ça veut dire qu'il
ya aucune exception alors qu'il ya plein
d'exception une loi normalement ne
tolère pas l'exception
alors qu'il ne pourrait pas l on
pourrait appeler ça des tendances on va
dire voilà la tendance des fossiles
similaire bon là on l'appellera la loi
des fossiles similaire mais comprenez
tendance des fossiles similaires c'est à
dire que deux roches sédimentaires qui
contiennent le même faux cils
ce sont certainement formé au même âge
et donc peuvent être corrélés peuvent
être datés de approximativement la même
période donc ici si vous suivez cette
huître en bleu la dent vous avez ici
plusieurs zones géographiques
différentes donc on est dans peut être
dans quatre coins du monde tout à fait
différent est ici dans la zone c vous
avez une huître bleu et dans la zone à
vous avez l'huître bleus qui est plus
basse dans la stratigraphie dans une
autre type de roche vous voyez que là
c'est une roche qui élite et alors que
là c'est une roche qui et granuleuse là
vous retrouvez votre huîtres dans une
réalité est là on retrouve pas d'huîtres
du tout bon bah on peut au moins dire
que dans cette partie là cette partie là
et cette partie là tant ces trois zones
sont du même âge et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que systématiquement
au-dessus des huîtres bleus on retrouve
ses petits
ces petits cônes ouvert et les petits
cônes verts ils sont aussi là il
aussi là et on les retrouve ici donc ça
veut dire qu'en fait la partie des
huîtres bleus n'est pas préservée dans
la zone des mais qu'elle est en dessous
en fait et tout ça ça permet d'aligner
en fait ces roches de cette façon donc
ça permet de corréler les roches de
différentes zones géographiques
et ça c'est très très très utilisé dans
l'industrie parce que on n'a pas
toujours les moyens de faire des
datation absolue donc les datation
absolue scélérat de le carbone 14 par
exemple c'est une datation radio
chronologique donc qui utilisent la
radioactivité il y en a d'autres qui
permettent de dater des roches plus
anciennes comme le potassium d'argon par
exemple vous avez des datations des
datations qui sont faites grâce aux
enfin des datation absolue qui sont
faites grâce à d'autres méthodes d une
méthode qui utilise en fait le fait que
les bombardements uv sur la roche vont
créer des isotopes et que c'est une fois
enterré en fait le ratio isotopique est
conservé et enfin non vont créer des
éléments radioactifs pardon et ses
bombes à eau est ce que c'est les uv ou
les rayons gamma je sais plus mais bref
pour une fois que la roche et intérêts
en gros ces éléments radioactifs vont
commencer à se désintégrer du coup on
peut dater on peut dater l'enterrement
de la roche en fait donc le moment où
une strate est venue recouvrir cette
roche donc si vous avez un
enregistrement continu
normalement vous avez la date de votre
roche si vous avez une si vous avez une
discordance là par contre ça marche pas
mais bon voilà vous avez l'idée on peut
faire ça aussi sur des aspects de ce
qu'on appelle des spéléo thème donc
c'est à dire les les concrétions
calcaires les concrétions de calcite
dans les grottes
on peut les dates et aussi avec d'autres
éléments radioactifs
il n'y a pas il ya plein de technique il
ya évidemment la technique qui utilise
le magnétisme terrestre les inversions
de champ magnétique terrestre ça aussi
ça permet de dater les roches donc voilà
on utilise a en plus des fossiles mais
surtout ce qui est intéressant en fait
c'est que vous allez aux industries ça
leur permet d'économiser de l'argent
parce que par exemple ici vous avez la
zone c dans la zone c imaginons que ici
ce soit la surface vous avez cette roche
à l'affleurement donc la roche avec les
huîtres bleus
et là vous allez dater cette roche là en
imaginant qu'il ya un moyen de la date
est alors généralement le meilleur moyen
de date est une roche c'est qu'ils y
aider ce qui est une couche volcaniques
dans la région si vous avez une couche
volcaniques qui est qui et par exemple
encastré à l'intérieur de cette de cette
couche qui contient des huîtres vous
allez connaître la date de votre huîtres
parce que les roches volcaniques elles
contiennent des éléments radioactifs
intéressant vous pouvez utiliser aussi
les zircon qui sont des petits des
petits éléments radioactifs localisés
dans des cristaux de quartz donc ce qui
vous permet de les cristaux de quartz et
du sable tout simplement donc ça vous
permet de vous affranchir de la
nécessité absolue de trouver une couche
volcaniques mais ça marche moins bien ça
marche un petit peu moins bien les
cristaux de quartz le zircon mais ça
marche quand même un peu ça veut dire
quand on a pas mieux on s'en contente
très bien mais voilà vous pouvez du coup
ici date et la roche à huîtres dans la
zone c est du coup quand vous retrouvez
cette roche à huîtres dans les forages
ici parce que encore une fois la surface
allait en eau
si vous retrouvez cette roche à 8 dans
les forages de la zone à et de la zone b
bat vous n'avez pas besoin de re date et
le forage en fait vous savez déjà que
cette zone là elle date de la date qu'on
a trouvé dans la zone c'est donc et ça
c'est intéressant ça c'est très
intéressant du coup ça permet
d'économiser de l'argent parce que les
datations ça coûte cher
tout simplement et connaître les dates
c'est important parce qu'on va le voir
après ça la date de l'âge de votre
rochelle va déterminer la qualité des
produits que vous y trouvez non mais on
va reparler de ça après voilà ça c'est
la loi de corrélation bio
stratigraphique c'est à dire que vous
trouvez le même faux cils ça veut dire
que la roche et du même âge
évidemment plus vous avez de fossiles
plus vous avez de chevauchement entre
vos faux cils et mieux c'est et c'est
pour ça qu'on utilise ce qu'on appelle
les fossiles indicateurs ou des fossiles
index qui sont de bons marqueurs
stratigraphique alors il faut quatre
ingrédients pour faire un très beau
fossiles
un très bon marqueur stratigraphique des
fossiles indicateurs de biostratigraphie
le premier c'est qu'il faut trouver
beaucoup de ce fossile
parce que si vous trouvez aussi il ya qu
un seul exemplaire dans le monde
basiquement votre fosse il sert à rien
le deuxième c'est qu'il faut que ce
fossile se retrouve partout dans le
monde ou dans une large zone
géographique
encore une fois si votre fossiles est
très abondant que dans un seul coin du
monde
on s'en fout ça permet pas de faire des
corrélations à grande échelle
ça va permettre de faire des
corrélations dans votre petit bassin à
voula de 40 kilomètres carrés mais ce
bon c'est moyennement intéressant autant
que faire se peut ce fossile doit avoir
une vie courte
à savoir une existence courte si vous
avez un fossile qui voit là si je
prenais un pronom la famille des
coelacanthe par exemple qui se trouve du
dévonien jusqu'à aujourd'hui trouver un
fossile de ces là quand ça va pas
beaucoup nous aider parce que il couvre
une région stratigraphique un peu large
voilà par contre vous trouvez un mégalo
dont la la ça tout de suite ça rétrécit
le champ des possibles c'est soit du
milieu scène supérieur soit du pliocène
enfin c'est soit de la deuxième moitié
du milieu scène soit du pliocène donc
megalodon c'est un meilleur marqueur
stratigraphique que le coelacanthe les
trilobites sont très utilisés comme
marqueurs stratigraphique déjà parce que
on trouve des trilobites que pendant le
paléozoïque donc quand vous trouvez un
trilobites vous êtes déjà à peu près sûr
que vous êtes dans le paléozoïque et pas
dans le mésozoïque ou le semnoz rich et
après les feux les trilobites même ont
évolué très vite et se sont succédé très
vite donc ça fait les très bons
marqueurs stratigraphique et enfin il
faut que ce fossile soit identifiable et
notamment quand il est partielle parce
que les fossiles ça préserve pas
toujours très bien donc si vous pouvez
identifier votre fossiles même quand il
n'est pas en entier c'est encore mieux
par exemple les dinos et fall sont de
très bons marqueurs stratigraphique
pourquoi parce que leur zoo sont d'une
épaisseur considérable et que dans le
permien il ya aucun autre animal qui a
une épaisseur d'os équivalente
même dans le paléozoïque en général
d'ailleurs
paléozoïque et même au début du trias il
y avait pas encore y avait pas d'animaux
avec une épaisseur d'ossements donc si
vous trouvez à anna hausse énorme hyper
hyper épais hyper dense
vous êtes à peu près sûr qu'il
appartient dinos et fall et que du coup
votre rochelle date du permien moyens
alors avec d'autres fossiles
d'indicateurs évidemment pour essayer de
soutenir votre votre hypothèse
évidemment tout ça c'est des hypothèses
de corrélation que vous faites et plus
vous avez de fossiles indicateurs et
voire même de date faite par datation
absolue
plus vous êtes plus vous êtes proche de
la vérité
on va dire en tout cas vous avez plus
vous avez une image cohérente
par contre si vous avez des fossiles qui
vous renvoie une image pas cohérente du
tout c'est qu'il ya un problème mais ça
c'est aussi un truc que j'essaye de dire
aux étudiants parce que évidemment après
on fait des entraînements des dtp et
quand quand ils ont d identification de
fossiles qui donne deux âges qui sont
complètement contradictoire j'essaie de
le redire mais me rends pas ta copie
comme ça me rend pas ta copie comme ça
avec deux identification ton cul c'est
qu'au moins une des deux fosses essaye
de voir laquelle des deux fosses au
moins c'est si tu trouves 2h
complètement différent dans la même
roche c'est qu'il ya un problème
donc soit il ya du remaniement
et dans ce cas là tu cherches des
indices de remaniement donc le
remaniement c'est quand un vieux fossile
remonte mais dans ce cas là tu prends le
plus vieux des deux et essayer de voir
si le plus vieux des deux il n'est pas
super héros des parce que là que comme
ça que ça peut se former le remaniement
c'est le camarade de
vale vale aux raptor pourra vous en
parler on retrouve des dent de dinosaure
dans des roches du miocène des roches
cénozoïque les dinosaures normalement
ils ont disparu depuis au moins trente
millions d'années à ce moment là voire
plus mais on retrouve quand même des
danses du dinosaure dans ce milieu scène
mais ses dents elles sont super héros d
et elles sont fossilisés d'une façon
différente l'on voit que on voit que le
processus taffonneau milk qui a qui a
fossilisés cédant est complètement
différent du processus taphonomie qu des
fossiles qui eux date réellement du
miocène et les fossiles du miocène ne
sont pas érodé ou le sont moins donc
vous voyez c'est faux faut essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe faut pas
juste contenté de dire valade
ah bah tiens ce fossile adepte du
mésozoïque ce fossile là ils datent du
milieu scène
bon bah c'est ou du mésozoïque ou du
miocène c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
la façon dont ça marche c'est que
s'arrogent alouettes du miocène et soit
tu t'es planté sur ton truc du miso x
soit c'est du remaniement
soit c'est un truc du miocène où tu t'es
planté d'ailleurs mais enfin il ya un
truc qui ne va pas et donc c'est comme
ça qu'on fait on c'est un processus d
ses erreurs et puis on jusqu'à ce qu'on
obtienne une image cohérente et
cohérente aussi avec les datation
absolue ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
mais bon ça ça avance mais petit à petit
c'est pas ça se fait pas magiquement
c'est c'est un processus d'essai erreurs
qu'on essaie d'inculquer aux étudiants
d'abord obtenir une image cohérente et
puis voir si sakho 6 est cohérent avec
quand on y rajoute deux nouveaux
fossiles c'est à chaque fois qu'on
découvre un nouveau fossile dans une
région dont on croit connaître l'âge
c'est un coup de dés c'est à dire que
soit on a raison c'est le bon âge et on
va trouver un fossile qui est cohérent
avec cet âge là soit bah c'est pas le
cas et puis il va falloir se remettre en
question c'est pour ça que quand vous
avez des créationnistes qui vous font
des grands discours sur sur le voilà le
lait déluge biblique et tout ça qui ont
mélangé tout les coups oui c'est la
t'explique comment les trucks ont fini
en trm et explique pas comment ça se
fait qu'ils sont organisées dans une
séquence cohérente c'est
c'est pour ça que ça ça me rend un peu
fou furieux parce que c'est ça veut dire
que vous enfin pour pour être
créationnistes il faut nier complètement
l'existence de ces fossiles un
indicateur et pour nier l'existence de
ces fossiles indicateurs il faut nier
l'existence de la gravité
parce que c'est la gravité qui empile
les couches et c'est la gravité qui
donne cette cohérence c'est parce que à
un instant t un animal qui meurent ils
tombent sur le fond voilà il tombe sur
le fond de ou sur le sol
et c'est là qu'il faut s'y lisent donc
si vous partez du principe qu'il ya des
successions de roche mais que soi-disant
elles ont aucun sens parce que toute
façon tout a été mixé par le grand
déluge biblique ou je sais pas quoi ban
c'est parce qu'on voit donc vous n'ayez
vous nier l'existence de la gravité
voilà donc et vous niez par là-même 200
ans même plus parce que la stratigraphie
déjà la marque qu'il en faisait donc ça
fait au moins 300 en plus de 300 ans de
de ce processus d'essai erreur qui
conduit petit à petit un raffinement des
de cette connaissance de la bio
stratigraphique on a aujourd'hui qui est
très maintenant c'est très très
développé on pouvait trouver un fossile
en chine et dire qu'il est de la mer du
même âge qu'une roche qui se trouvent en
amérique du sud maintenant sans problème
en fonction de l'âge effectivement
et donc
il indexe jeu j'arrête ma digressions
ces fossiles index vous donne ce qu'on
appelle des biozone c'est à dire des
zones où on retrouve les mêmes fossiles
et cc biozone qu'on va appliquer dans
l'utilisation de la bio stratigraphique
par exemple si vous aviez la biozone à
huîtres bleus est ici vous avez une bio
zone à qui sert à rien d'ailleurs
puisqu'on la retrouve nulle part
ailleurs mais c'est une biozone à étoile
de mer pourpre enfin mauvais et ici vous
avez une bio zone a connu vers qui elle
est très utile parce qu'on la retrouve
dans toutes les zones
c'est elle qui permet de corréler
d'ailleurs les trois zones enfin les
quatre zones pardon
et dans une moindre mesure on va utile
va aussi utiliser parfois le ce qu'on
appelle la loi de succession évolutive
ou la tendance des successions évolutive
à savoir que des fossiles
les fossiles qui sont qui ont les traits
de les caractères les plus évolués se
retrouvent généralement après les
fossiles qui ont des caractères qui sont
plus primitifs enfin se retrouvent dans
des les fossiles avec les caractères
plus évolués vont se retrouver dans des
roches plus jeunes que les fossiles qui
montre des caractère primitif
ça marche pas toujours encore une fois
le coelacanthe le coelacanthe par
rapport à tétrapodes il a beaucoup de
caractère primitif
pourtant on le retrouve dans les mêmes
enfin on retrouve encore aujourd'hui
donc ça marche pas toujours donc encore
une fois appeler ça une loi là pour le
coup ça se voit vraiment que ça marche
moins bien mais généralement ça marche
si vous retrouvez un australopithèque
globalement vous savez que vous êtes
dans les alentours de 3 4 millions d
entre 2 et 4 millions d'années si vous
retrouvez si vous retrouvez moi je ne
sais pas megalodon encore une fois non
bah megalodon le problème c'est que oui
bah si vous retrouvez megalodon vous
savez que vous êtes sur la fin de
l'existence de la ligne et autobus mega
mega c'est la cus megalodon afin de
l'aligner au taux du smega c'est la cus
sachant que cette lignée commence au
crétacé donc vous êtes sur la fin de la
ligne et donc vous êtes plutôt milieu
cénozoïque mais bon voilà c'est comme je
le disais c'est quelque chose qui a ses
limites
ça marche très bien avec les invertébrés
par exemple pour les trucs dont on
trouve des centaines de fossiles tout le
temps partout tout le temps ça marche
relativement bien ça marche beaucoup
moins bien avec les vertébrés pour
lequel le registre fossile est un peu
plus parcellaire maintenant on va parler
d'un cas que je connais bien d'une
implication de l'application directe de
ce système de biostratigraphie qui est
le caroux donc le caroux qui hélas un
grand bassin qui s'étant quasiment de
johannesbourg ici jusqu'au cap ici et
cette immense bassin il fait à peu près
un tiers de la taille de la france et
toutes les roches que vous voyez là sont
corrélés par biostratigraphie et
essentiellement très peu de il ya très
peu finalement deux dates absolue qui
ont pu être tirés parce que il n'ya pas
d'interpellation enfin il ya peu
d'interpellations volcaniques dans ce
bassin c'est surtout du sédiment est bon
maintenant on commence à trouver quand
même des roches volcaniques un petit peu
par ci par là de ce qu'on appelle des ce
qu'on appelle des tubes qui permettent
de confirmer finalement que la
biostratigraphie qu'on fait depuis
quelques années est relativement
cohérente et elle l'est elle est très
cohérente
donc tous et toutes ses couleurs que
vous voyez ce sont des bio zones qui
sont définies par des espèces de thé
rapide essentiellement des dix hinault
d'hondt
mais pas que et est donc de tout ça
c'est voyez c'est chaque affleurements
que qui existent dans toute cette région
je le rappelle un tiers de la taille de
la france
un peu plus même chaque affleurements en
fait est corrélée aux autres en fonction
des fossiles qu'on y trouve
et ça permet de dessiner c'est bien
c'est biozone donc ça permet de voir
d'ailleurs que les plus anciennes
biozone la zone comme celle là tapi nocé
phallus par exemple se retrouvent
essentiellement à l'ouest du bassin et
en fait on a des zones concentriques de
biozone qui deviennent de plus en plus
jeunes jusqu'à la zone à signature ce
qui est une des dernières qu'on retrouve
autour des basaltes du volcan qui
s'appelle le drakensberg de l'ancien
volcan c'est un volcan du jurassique qui
s'appelle le drakensberg donc ça permet
en fait de voir la structure géologique
de ce bassin qui est couches les plus
anciennes autour et couches les plus
récentes au milieu donc ça permet aussi
de comprendre comment le bassin s'est
formé on voit donc que le bassin il a
une structure
donc quand on a les couches les plus
anciennes autour et qu'on a les couches
les plus récentes au milieu c'est une
structure qui ressemble à un synclinal
voilà donc le synclinal c'est ainsi les
couches qui ce sont des choses qui sont
en souffrir donc avec les couches
anciennes autour synclinal sourire et
les couches les plus récentes au milieu
bon c'est pas aussi simple que ça
puisque comme j'ai dit il ya un volcan
qui est passé au travers donc c'est pas
aussi simple que ça et puis les coudes
les successions sont plus épaisses de ce
côté là que de ce côté là donc
évidemment c'est pas juste un petit
synclinal bien sympa c'est plus
compliqué que ça mais en gros voilà ça
permet ça permet de faire une
interprétation géologique directement à
partir de la datation qu'on obtient des
roches en fonction des espèces qu'on a
deux dents et dans une moindre mesure on
peut appliquer le système de voile à la
loi de succession évolution évolutive
dans le sens où au début vous avez des
thérapies sites qui sont plutôt primitif
notamment les dinos céphalées et audi
synodaux et qu'à la fin vous avez des
thérapies sites qui sont plutôt dérivés
notamment
sinon hiatus qui est ainsi nos doutes
donc alors qu'au début il n'y a pas de
sinnoh d'hondt par exemple donc les les
animaux sont plus dérivés quand on va
vers le haut de la séquence
stratigraphique donc ça aussi ça permet
une datation relative des des roches du
caroux donc et ça permet aussi dé
corrélation dans le monde entier
par exemple dans la zone en jaune ici la
zone à tapis de cefalu son trouve des
dinos et fall comme en afrique australe
sociaux dont
et on peut corréler avec le reste du
monde parce qu'on trouve siaudeau en
russie qui est l'équivalent russe
d'austral ossio dont on retrouve si nos
faux nez us en chine et on retrouve
pendent pas faux nez us au brésil donc
tous sondés en teoz or ils sont
quasiment identiques et on les retrouve
aux quatre coins du monde ce qui permet
de corréler toutes ces couches la couche
dans laquelle on a retrouvé pendu pas
faux nez au brésil en chine et en russie
peuvent être tout corrélé avec la zone
at à pinos et phallus sud-africaine donc
il suffit qu'on obtienne une date à un
endroit donc là j'ai dit au pif en chine
en vrai on a aussi des dates en afrique
du sud mais je veux dire il suffit de
trouver une date à un endroit pour ce
pour ces fossiles donc si par exemple en
chine on date cette couche de 260
millions d'années ben on sait que les
mêmes couches fossilifères son de cet
âge au brésil en russie et en afrique du
sud du moins on peut faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable qu'elles sont delà du même
âge les gorgones obtient qu'on retrouve
dans cette zone en bleu qui s'appelle la
zone adapte aux quais fallu sous la zone
a dit si nos dons eh bien on les
retrouve aussi en tanzanie on les
retrouve aussi en russie et par exemple
si en russie en russie ils n'ont pas de
date encore une fois mais si par exemple
en russie ont retrouvé un âge de 255
millions d'années bon en réalité on à
cet âge là pareil il vient d'afrique du
sud c'est juste pour donner un peu de
diversité
c'est juste pour pas dire que tout vient
d'afrique du sud non plus mais encore
une fois on a des dates qui viennent
d'afrique du sud et qu'ils disent de 155
millions d'années mais imaginons que
cette date viennent de russie
eh ben ça permet de dire que tous ces
coins du monde sont corrélés avec ses
250 millions d'années en russie et les
signaux dont tu qu'on retrouve au cours
du trias et du jurassique devrais je
préciser d'ailleurs parce que treaty
l'eau dont il est plutôt du jurassique
et bien on retrouve ces mêmes treaty
l'odon idées on les retrouve aussi bien
en europe qu'en chine donc oligo qui fut
ce qu'on retrouve en angleterre si ma
mémoire est exact mais on retrouve aussi
des tris d'îlots dont il est en france
je crois qu'à un saint laurent de porc
ils ont en alsace enfin dans l'est du
moins ils ont ils ont ils semblent des
détritus l'odon idée on a bien noté
rieumes en chine et on a caliente à
terium en amérique du nord donc encore
une fois si on a une date
là pour le coup elle vient d'amérique
pour de vrai à 200 millions d'années on
sait que à 200 millions d'années vous
aviez tout ce beau monde qui vivait en
même temps dans le monde donc ça permet
aussi de dattes et l'afrique du sud à
200 millions d'années par exemple donc
c'est comme ça que ça marche les
corrélations si vous trouvez des
marqueurs stratigraphique partout dans
le monde ça vous permet de dire que tous
ces endroits du monde sont corrélés
et c'est comme ça qu'on a dit qu'on a
fini avec une échelle des temps
géologiques ici qui est complètement
calquer en fait sur les successions de
fossiles qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur et
c'est pour ça que c'est échelle de temps
géologique sont complètement basé sur
leur contenu fossilifère c'est pour ça
que le mésozoïque c'est l'âge des
dinosaures et des ammonites c'est pour
ça que le paléozoïque c'est l'âge des
trilobites c'est pour ça que le
cénozoïque c'est l'âge des mammifères
c'est parce que c'est parce que on a
c'est parce que les couches géologiques
elle même la dénomination des couches
géologiques est directement calqués sur
les contenus en fossiles et chaque fin
de chaque chaque fin en fait de ces de
ces strates la fin du cambrien la fin de
l'ordovicien la fin du silurien
correspond à des extinctions entre
guillemets massif papa massive dans le
sens des grands
les grandes extinctions massives comme
la limite permise trias sous la limite
crétacé tertiaire
mais ce sont des extinctions cd
remplacement de faune qui permettent de
dire bon bah voilà cette faune elle est
nouvelle et on retrouve cette faune là
là là là et là dans le monde donc ça
elles datent tous du même moment et ce
moment on va décider qu'on l'appelle le
silurien et pouf cette faune elle
s'éteint et à les remplacer par une
nouvelle forme qui est celle du dévonien
on va dire on retrouve cette fois ne
parlera pas par là et on va lui donner
le nom de des voix n'ya donc si vous
vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi les
airs géologique n'avait pas tout le
n'étaient pas toutes des intervalles
réguliers de temps en fait ben c'est
pour ça c'est parce que la vie ne se
développe pas intervalles réguliers
c'est un peu c'est un peu au pifomètre
quoi c'est complètement aléatoire
c'est en fonction en fait des
remplacements phonique et à chaque fois
qu'il ya un nouveau remplacement
phonique on a défini une nouvelle
période géologique ou de nouvelle époque
donc tout dépend les âges que vous
donnez donc voilà par exemple
voilà par exemple ici ce que je vous
disais l'âge des trilobites qui
correspond à l'ère du paléozoïque l'âge
des dinosaures aide et à mo'nique qui
correspond à l'ère du mésozoïque l'âge
des mammifères qui correspond à l'ère du
cénozoïque évidemment vous pourriez
ensuite partir dans le détail pour
chacune de ces périodes géologiques que
vous voyez là
le deuxième grand s'utilise la deuxième
grande utilisation c'est l'utilisation
enfin scientifique du moins des fossiles
c'est l'utilisation pour reconstruire
l'évolution des espèces donc là
généralement pour motiver mes petits
étudiant en géologie parce que
l'évolution des espèces ça les intéresse
moyens encore une fois c'est pas des
biologistes là je les motive en leur
disant que la vie est formé d'atomes que
ces atomes
comme tout d'ailleurs tout est formé
d'atomes mais je veux dire la vie est
formé d'atomes et que ces atomes
ils viennent d'eux ils viennent du
milieu minérale au final par exemple le
sens que vous allez le faire qui donne
la couleur rouge à votre sens c'est du
fer oxydé essai de la rouille cette
rouille c'est la même que celle que vous
trouvez dans le look site de faire à
l'état natif dans la roche et tout ça ça
vient d'où ça vient du fer qui s'est
formée lors de la dernière supernova que
notre système solaire enfin que le
système solaire qui nous a précédé a
subi supernova qui a formé ses atomes de
fer donc finalement le processus qui a
formé le faire dans la roche c'est le
même processus qui a formé le faire
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui dans notre
sens ce qui fait des êtres vivants juste
un type spécial de cailloux un petit peu
un petit peu mouvant finalement on et du
sable mouvant mai mais un peu plus
mouvant un peu plus peu plus émotif
aussi il ya quelques émotif à ce moment
là qu'ils qui soulève un sourcil et
soulève à son style aussi parce que le
créationnisme le créationnisme à la part
belle en afrique du sud
les communautés sont très religieuse
donc ils ont généralement leur rencontre
avec moi c'est aussi leur première
rencontre avec l'évolution
à moins qu'ils aient eu des cours
d'évolution humaine parce qu'évidemment
ils ont des cours d'évolution humaine
ans au lycée cours auquel ils n'ont pas
vraiment adhéré d'ailleurs pour la
plupart mais bref
donc à ce moment là je leur rappelle ce
qu'est l'évolution à leur montrant cette
image à savoir que l'évolution
l'évolution c'est juste de comprendre
comment cet arbre est arrivé enfin
comment les racines comme un fêtard bras
fini enraciné des deux côtés de ce trou
est donc là je
repose la question et puis bon bah ils
vont ils vont encore une fois ils vont
lever un sourcil en se disant que la
seule réponse qui leur vient à l'esprit
c'est une réponse débile du genre
d'arbres l'arbre a franchit pas lui-même
il a sauté il a sais pas quoi et il y en
a généralement un ou une qui finit par
lever la main en disant banon avant il y
avait de la terre mais c'est juste qu'il
ya eu un effondrement quelconque et je
leur dis exactement
l'évolution c'est juste de comprendre
que les choses n'ont pas toujours
étaient telles qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
qui s'est passé des choses dans le passé
notamment que le vivant a subi une
histoire dans le passé et c'est ça qu'on
fait quand on étudie l'évolution on
étudie l'histoire de la vie dans le
passé et là ça leur parle là niveau
géologique ça leur parle parce que parce
que finalement ça c'est pas juste
émettre des hypothèses comme ça
évolutive par ci par là c'est
reconstruire ce qui s'est passé dans le
passé et qui est enregistrée dans la
roche et ça c'est ce qui les intéresse
en tant que géologue et du coup ça nous
conduit à 7,7
cette représentation c'est que justement
si on creuse dans le passé et bien on
voit une succession en fait d'eux une
succession de 2 alors j'aime pas dire
complexité mais c'est une succession
finalement de de proximité des
organismes par rapport à nous voilà donc
si on plus on va dans le passé plus on
va trouver des animaux qui nous sont de
moins en moins proche donc on commence
avec les humains quand on retrouve des
fossiles jusqu'à 300 mille ans donc là
je parle d' homo sapiens et quand on
remonte dans le passé jusqu'à trois
millions d'années on va trouver
australopithecus donc eux ils le
connaissent bien généralement parce que
on l'appelle le mandrake donc l'homme
sage en anglais donc australopithèques
us ils l'ont généralement bien étudié en
au lycée ou alors ils vont l'étudier
d'ici peu avec un de mes collègues
puisqu'il ya un programme d'évolution
humaine qui vient juste après qui est
qui et qui est donnée par un de mes
collègues
et puis si on remonte jusqu'à 65
millions d'années on trouve des primates
donc là c'est aussi là que le côté
d'avoir abordé la taxonomie est
intéressant parce que du coup ils se
rendent compte qu'on s'éloigne en fait
de l'être humain
quand on parle des primates et quand on
remonte jusqu'à 200 millions d'années on
trouve les premiers mammifères et à 320
millions d'années on trouve les premiers
reptiles et à 400 millions d'années on
retrouve les premiers amphibiens et à
540 millions d'années on retrouve les
premiers poissons et les premiers la
première bible les premières traces de
vie multicellulaires sont à 2 milliards
d'années et les premières traces de vie
tout court sont à trois points 5
milliards d'années 35.8 il ya débat il y
en a même qui disent 4,1 mais bref voilà
l'important dans cette image c'est de
comprendre qu en fait plus on s'éloigne
plus on creuse en fait
et plus on trouve des animaux et des
organismes qui sont éloignés de nous et
donc ça ça retrace l'évolution des
espèces en tout cas de notre espèce
c'est ça qui est important ici c'est de
bien comprendre que c'est la roche
cesser le registre fossile de la roche
qui documentent l'évolution des espèces
et qui documentent aussi leur extinction
un autre un autre élément important de
l'évolution c'est le fait que les
espèces
c'est le fait que les espèces
apparaissent donc ce qu'on appelle la
spéciation et de ce fait on doit voir
on doit voir de nouvelles espèces
apparaître si l'évolution fonctionne
telle qu'on croit qu'elle fonctionne et
c'est le cas donc là si on regarde alors
ici c'est le nombre de genres mais le
nombre de genres est directement
proportionnel aux gens au nombre
d'espèces et on voit que ben on part de
zéro et qu'on arrive finalement à
beaucoup si je puis dire
donc ça c'est une augmentation
généralement en général elles plutôt une
augmentation du nombre d'espèces donc il
y as spéciation il y as apparition de
nouvelles espèces alors que s'il n'y
avait pas apparition de nouvelles
espèces dont on devrait pas voir cette
augmentation
mais quand même il faut noter que cette
augmentation elle est ponctuée
généralement ils ne mettent pas
longtemps à s'en rendre compte les
étudiants je veux dire ils sont
observateur les étudiants se rend compte
assez rapidement que c'est quand même
ponctué de grosses extinction voilà deux
moments où en fait c'est pas une
augmentation jolie et régulière c'est
une augmentation qui est ponctué de
baisse de diversité qu'on appelle des
extinctions de masse et qu'il ya quatre
grandes extinctions de masse celle de la
fin de l'ordovicien celle de la fin du
dévonien gély 4g il ya cinq grandes
extinctions de masse la fin de
l'ordovicien la fin du dévonien la fin
du permien la fin du trias et la fin du
crétacé donc là c'est la fin des
dinosaures très connu la limite par la
limite crétacé tertiaire
ici vous avez la limite entre le
paléozoïque et le mésozoïque qui est la
plus marquée la plus grosse extinction
de tout et qui donc défini la fin de
l'ère paléozoïque et le début de l'ère
mésozoïque donc ça c'est la limite
permise trias vous avez la plus petite
limite qui définit la fin du permien et
les autres petites limites qui
définissent la fin du dévonien et la fin
de l'ordovicien bien que celle de la fin
du dévonien sont pas exactement à la fin
du dévonien mais ça c'est du détail est
quelque chose qui parle aussi beaucoup
aux étudiants c'est de voir que
l'évolution des espèces est un vecteur
d'égalité sociale savoir savoir d'où
l'on vient c'est aussi savoir que les
autres c'est aussi ne pas laisser les
autres vous faire croire que eux savent
mieux que vous d'où vous venez c'est
c'est quelque chose d'important
tous les grands tous les grands
dictateurs de ce monde ont commencé par
réécrire l'histoire de l'évolution tous
et même avant avant même d'être des
dictateurs d'ailleurs toutes les grandes
dictatures ont d'abord commencé dans la
tête de quelqu'un qui est qui a voulu
réécrire l'histoire de l'évolution
les gens qui veulent dominer d'autres
gens commencent d'abord par s'inventer
une origine différente des gens qui
veulent dominer donc et ça ça parle
beaucoup dans un contexte sud africain
puisque évidemment il ya toute
l'histoire de l'apartheid ou d'ailleurs
le gouvernement d'apartheid était très
très très créationnistes
et donc voilà et il ya aussi le fait que
tout simplement la théorie de
l'évolution
elle dit qu on vient tous du même
endroit on vient tous de la même
population d'homo sapiens nous sommes
tous pareils et nous sommes juste le pr
et nous sommes le produit de la même
évolution sans rentrer encore une fois
dans le détail troisième usage delà des
fossiles en pour la paléontologie pour
la science c'est la paléo géographie
donc exemple le très classique celui de
la dérive des continents
on retrouve les mêmes fossiles de part
et d'autre d'un océan ou deux parties en
fin de l'atlantique on les retrouve
aussi en inde
on les retrouve aussi en antarctique ce
qui veut dire que les 3 que ces quatre
pardon continent était autrefois unis
unis par parle à la dérive des
continents
donc ce qu'on appelle ce qu'on appelle
le continent gondwana
donc on peut faire de la corrélation
mais quand on a aussi des animaux qui
vivaient dans des débuts qui étaient
soit complètement terrestre soit qu'ils
étaient voire même le mieux c'est
d'utiliser des animaux qui vivaient dans
l'eau douce ou dans des petites mer
intérieure comme le mezzo russe parce
que les animaux d'eau douce ils ne
peuvent pas voyager beaucoup ne peuvent
pas voyager beaucoup d'un point d'eau
douce à un autre généralement les
animaux d'eau douce ils ont une
répartition qui est très très limité
géographiquement et donc si vous trouvez
le même animal d'eau douce de part et
d'autre d'un océan c'est pas l'animal
d'eau douce qui a nagé dans l'eau salée
parce qu'un animal d'eau douce peut pas
vraiment s'adapter aussi facilement que
ça à l'eau salée donc c'est que il ya
forcément eu les deux continents étaient
en connexion d'une manière ou d'une
autre à un moment donné et ça et ça
marche avec mes aux eaux russes
notamment parce que mai au zoo russie
vivaient dans une petite mer intérieure
il avait une répartition très très
limité et cette petite mer intérieure du
coup on en retrouve les mêmes dépôt de
l'autre côté en amérique du sud donc
l'explication la plus simple c'est quand
même de dire que l'amérique du sud et
l'afrique étaient connectés
et puis reconstruire les
paléoenvironnements les paléo climat
c'est aussi une chose qu'on peut faire
avec les fossiles donc très rapidement
les espèces marines vont vous indiquer
qu'il y avait la mer surprise mais après
on peut même distinguer entre les
espèces marines d'eaux profondes comme
les listes de mer les espèces marines
qui vivent dans les mains des milieux
peu profonds comme les coraux donc
celles qui ont besoin les coraux ils ont
des algues photosynthétiques qui ont
besoin de lumière donc elles peuvent pas
vivre à grande profondeur donc les
organismes qui vivent de la
photosynthèse globalement ne peuvent pas
vivre à grande profondeur
après vous avez des organismes qui font
la chimiosynthèse qui eux sont utilisent
les les
la chimie est la chaleur des de ce qu'on
appelle les fumeurs noirs et qui eux
vivent dans les eaux très profondes
donc ce sont des marqueurs d'eau
profonde vous avez des espèces qui
vivent uniquement dans les tropiques et
vous avez des espèces qui vivent
uniquement dans les eaux froides comme
par exemple les abandonnent les abalone
vivent plutôt dans des eaux froides donc
et alors que vous avez les coraux encore
une fois qui vivent dans des zones
plutôt tropicale donc rien qu'en
regardant les fossiles que vous avez
vous êtes capable de déterminer quels
étaient l'environnement marin qui
existait à un instant à un moment
évidemment faut pas que ces fossiles est
été transporté
vous avez des organismes qui vivent
typiquement dans les eaux plutôt smith
allez on va dire donc les eaux qu'on
appelle les eaux lagunaires par exemple
donc typiquement l'organisme de lagune
c'est là l'un gül donc là la gueule qui
est un petit brachiopodes qui ressemble
à une langue
d'où son nom vous avez aussi les requins
tigres qui sont des requins qui vivent
essentiellement dans les eaux d'estuaire
donc pas vraiment dans l'est dans les
eaux de pas vraiment dans les lagunes
mais ils peuvent remonter dans la lagune
mais ils vivent surtout dans les
estuaires et vous avez les petites
planeur qui vivent dans les eaux douces
et dans les eaux smith allait aussi et
vous et vous avez enfin les espèces
terrestres strictement thérèse donc
typiquement les vertébrés qui vont aussi
vous indiquer si l'environnement était
été rocheux et chaud si l'environnement
était plutôt forêts tropicales
si l'environnement était plutôt
aquatique ou si l'environnement était
froid voilà en fonction d'eux en
fonction de l'animal que vous trouvez
vous pouvez dire dire quel type
d'environnement il y avait encore une
fois tout ça se basent énormément sur ce
qu'on appelle le principe d' actualiser
c'est à dire qu'il faut avoir quand même
un point de comparaison moderne ce qui
n'est pas forcément évident mais si vous
trouvez si vous trouvez des mammifères
là vous pouvez avoir un point de
comparaison tout à fait viable
donc voilà si vous trouvez un fossile de
capi vous êtes à peu près sûr que il y
avait une forêt tropicale là où vous
vous trouviez par exemple ça c'est pas
c'est pas trop un problème
et enfin la dernière utilisation c'est
pour trouver des ressources des
ressources qui seront utilisables de
façon industrielle donc par exemple l'or
l'or est une ressource qui est très
abondante en afrique du sud notamment
c'est une ressource qui est très
abondante en afrique mais qui se
retrouve uniquement dans des roches de
type sédimentaires l'or pour l'instant
en afrique du sud on l'a pas retrouvée
dans d'autres roches que des roches de
type sédimentaires donc on sait que cet
or a été arraché du nôtre roche pour se
retrouver dans des dépôts qui sont des
dépôts de ce sont des conglomérats donc
c'est des dépôts de rivière en fait mais
on
et pas d'où ça vient exactement quelle
était la quelle était la roche originale
par contre on a ces dépôts conglomérat
tic autour de johannesbourg notamment et
donc c'est pas déjà trouvait à trouver
un fossile c'est un indicateur de si on
est dans une roche sédimentaire ou pas
mais le truc c'est avec l'or c'est qu'on
ne trouve jamais dans des roches
sédimentaires du fan héroïque donc le
fan est rose os x est la période qui
s'étend de 540 millions d'années donc
c'est là où on est le cambrien etc
jusqu'aux cénozoïque donc si vous
trouvez à fossiles vous êtes dans le fan
héroïque
enfin si vous trouvez beaucoup de faux
cils vous êtes dans le fan héroïque
donc certes vous êtes en train de
regarder des roches sédimentaires mais
pas des roches sédimentaires dans lequel
on trouve l'or qui parce que l'or lui il
se trouve en aux environs de 2 5
milliards d'années donc dans le pré
cambrien les dépôts d'or ils sont entre
3 milliards et 2 5 milliards d'années
donc il se trouve plutôt par là et ça ça
du coup le fait simplement de trouver un
fossile
bah ça vous a dit que directement vous
n'avez aucune chance de trouver de l'or
par exemple
vous voyez donc ça ces indicateurs par
contre si vous trouvez des stromatolites
là vous avez peut-être une chance parce
que les stromatolithes en afrique du sud
on retrouve beaucoup dans ces périodes
là autour de 2,7 milliards d'années donc
ça permet d'aider à trouver de l'or
stromatolithes c'est à peu près le seul
fossiles que vous pourrez trouver à
proximité d'un dépôt où il ya de l'or
tout simplement
donc vous avez vous aidé de la géologie
puisque le dépôt géologique c'est un
dépôt de conglomérats donc c'est assez
visible mais vous allez aussi vous aider
du contenu en fossiles pour pouvoir vous
repérer dans les roches que vous êtes en
train d'explorer à la recherche d'or et
puis il ya aussi par exemple le diamant
et les les ressources l'uranium par
exemple la radioactivité donc ces
ressources là contrairement à l'or ne
vont pas se trouver dans des roches
sédimentaires mais vont se retrouver
plus tôt dans des roches de type
volcanique donc des roches magmatiques
qui proviennent du finalement du manteau
donc qui proviennent de l'intérieur de
la terre donc c'est la grosse différence
qu'il ya entre les roches sédimentaires
et les roches magmatiques les roches
sédimentaires tombe par gravité à se
forme pas ce qu'elle tombe pour graviter
généralement dans l'océan alors que les
roches magmatiques elles elles viennent
du fond de la terre elles viennent du
manteau donc elle monte elle se forme en
montant elle se forme pas en descendant
comme les roches sédimentaires et ses
roches qui se forme en montant il ya
aucun moment où elle rencontre quelque
chose qui pourra y mettre des fossiles
donc ces roches
magmatique sont dépourvus de fossiles ce
qui est une fois de plus est une
indication de quel type de roche vous
êtes en train de regarder si jamais vous
avez un doute si vous n'y trouvez aucun
fossile il ya de fortes chances que vous
soyez face à une roche de type
magmatique donc l'or se trouve dans les
roches sédimentaires
par contre les diamants eux se trouvent
exclusivement encore une fois en afrique
du sud
elles se trouvent exclusivement dans des
roches de type magmatique elles se
trouvent dans des cheminées volcaniques
qu'on appelle des kimberley tu donc
c'est des diamants qui sont remontées en
fait avec les kimber avec la remontée de
magma
donc si vous aussi vous trouvez des
fossiles
encore une fois vous savez que vous
n'êtes pas en train de chercher au bon
endroit si vous aussi ce que vous voulez
c'est des diamants et si vous voulez de
la radioactivité il va vous falloir du
granit qui ose qui est aussi une roche
magmatique donc vous n'êtes pas non plus
au bon endroit pour chercher du granit
encore que on peut avoir des
concentrations de d'uranium dans des
roches sédimentaires ça peut arriver
mais encore une fois tout dépend de ce
que vous recherchez
et en fonction de ce que vous recherchez
il est bien de savoir quel type de
fossiles aussi vous êtes susceptible de
trouver ou non dans les roches qui
contiennent la ressource que vous êtes
en train de chercher donc connaître sa
paléontologie c'est aussi une porte
ouverte vers des ressources et ses
ressources elles ne sont pas forcément
ça n'a pas forcément être que du voilà
que de l'or bien du pétrole le pétrole
d'ailleurs c'est des comme le charbon
c'est ce qu'on appelle des ressources
fossiles
voilà des énergies fossiles donc c'est
pas pour rien que ça s'appelle des
énergies fossiles c'est parce qu'elles
sont formés par des organismes c'est des
organismes qui se sont décomposées et
dont la décomposition incomplète a causé
des accumulations de carbone donc ces
organismes des composés ils ne peuvent
se trouver par définition que dans des
roches sédimentaires
et vous n'avez pas que les ressources
comme je le disais les ressources
minérales vous avez aussi des ressources
qui sont l'agriculture et l'eau l'eau
qui devient de plus en plus importante
parce que les sécheresses deviennent de
plus en plus fréquentes et on a eu un
exemple il n'ya pas longtemps au cap le
cap qui a failli juste privé d'eau vous
imaginez une grande ville de plusieurs
millions d'habitants qui a juste failli
être privé d'eau à cause de la
sécheresse
donc l'eau c'est une ressource qui va
généralement se trouvaient dans des
roches sédimentaires qui sont plus
poreuses et tout ça va évidemment avoir
un effet sur les sur la façon dont on
gère l'agriculture s'éteindre roches
sédimentaires sont très riches certaines
roches sédimentaires ne le sont pas
certaines roches magmatiques comme le
basalte peuvent être très riche et
d'autres peuvent ne pas l'être
donc encore une fois la connaissance du
registre fossile c'est aussi l'accès à
des ressources et pas seulement des
ressources minérales
et puisque justement on parle du pétrole
le contenu en fossiles des roches qui
entoure le pétrole va être un indicateur
de sa maturité à savoir que si vous
trouvez des pollens prend l'exemple des
pollens si vous trouvez des pollens dont
la ce propos lénine est très clair comme
ça ça veut dire que votre ça veut dire
que le pétrole que vous trouvez à
l'intérieur de cette roche ne va pas
être mature il n'a pas assez cuit il est
pas il n'est pas à point
j'ai envie de dire par contre si vous
trouvez des pollens qui sont carbonisés
ben là ça veut dire que c'est trop
profond qui a trop de pression qui a
trop de température et là vous avez dans
l'anthracite vous avez pu du pétrole
l'anthracite c'est beaucoup moins
intéressant que le pétrole vous ce que
vous voulez c'est des petits pollen qui
sont juste bien cuire al dente
voilà eh ben ça c'est directement
utilisés par l'industrie pétrolière
donc c'est un outil une utilisation des
fossiles directement par l'industrie
pétrolière
c'est la cdc des trucs qui sont dans les
manuels voilà donc c'est pas un truc que
j'ai dont j'exagère là c'est pas un truc
donges exagérerait l'importance juste
pour vous mettre l'eau à la bouche quoi
c'est vraiment un truc qui est
directement utilisés
et puis la dernière utilisation des
fossiles dans l'industrie s'est
évidemment l'industrie du palais au
tourisme dont classe à ce que je vous
montre c'est le tumulus de marot peng
qui est à 50 km de johannesbourg c'est
le sait le site
enfin c'est un musée en fait qui est
complètement dédié aux cradle of
humankind donc le berceau de l'humanité
qui est la région unesco alors encore
une fois c'est pas moi qu'ils appellent
le berceau de l'humanité c'est l'unesco
qui l'appelle comme ça c'est pas la
peine de me harceler en commentaire
c'est le berceau de l'humanité c'est
toute la région qui se trouve à peu près
à 50 km de johannesbourg où on a trouvé
tout un tas de grottes et donc l'unesco
protège ce site parce que ces grottes
contiennent des australopithèques des
homo habilis des homo erectus on n'y a
trouvé little foot il n'ya pas longtemps
on n'y a trouvé au monal est dit on n'y
a trouvé australopithecus sediba c'est
là que le premier australopithèques a
été découvert l'enfant de tang
c'est là que le premier
australopithèques adulte a été découvert
mais s'il se laisse donc bref c'est un
grand lieu à la fois historiques et
préhistoriques
donc tout ça est protégé par l'unesco et
au milieu vous avez ce musée qui
s'appelle marc open gay qui est
l'exemple même du palais au tourisme
alors après en france vous avez vous
avez des tas de sites paléo touristique
que ce soit des musées que ce soit le
site d'angeac enfin bref ça il ya le dès
qu'on peut faire un peu d'argent sur de
la paléontologie ça s'appelle du palais
au tourisme voilà en faisant visiter ou
etc
voilà c'était tout pour cette
introduction à la paléontologie et à ce
qu'on peut faire avec
je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi je
vous dis à la semaine prochaine pour la
suite de ce court où on attaquera les
invertébrés d'ailleurs